bien le bonjour à toutes et tous
je salue bien sûr Monsieur Laurent
Guillaume
alors voici tout juste un an suite à la
publication du livre les fossoyeurs
notre commission des affaires sociales
c'est saisi de l'ensemble des questions
soulevées par l'ouvrage de Monsieur
Castanet
plus d'eau que de céder aussi Rennes
bien séduisante d'une inutile commission
d'enquête dont la mise en place aurait
été trop longue et le temps de travail
excessivement court en raison de la
campagne électorale nous avons préféré
faire œuvre utile en procédant entre le
9 février donc je disais il y a tout
juste un an entre le 9 février et le 9
mars à de très nombreux auditions et en
lançant parallèlement quatre missions
flash transpartizane qui ont elles-mêmes
de elle-même auditionner 140 personnes
et effectivement voilà le rapport
qui est là devant vous alors même que le
Sénat venait à peine de mettre en place
sa propre commission d'enquête ou
demeurant sur un champ d'investigation
beaucoup plus limité notre commission a
été en mesure dès le 9 mars de publier
un rapport de 550 pages dont le
gouvernement a très vite retenu un
certain nombre de recommandations
nous avions commencé cette très
importante série de travaux par un
échange avec Monsieur Philippe charrier
alors président directeur général du
groupe ORPEA et Monsieur Jean-Christophe
remercie directeur général France
échange n'est d'ailleurs pas du tout le
mot approprié car beaucoup d'entre nous
qui étaient déjà présents l'an dernier
s'en souviennent certainement cette
audition tenait davantage d'un monologue
que d'un dialogue j'y avais mis fin en
constatant que la représentation
nationale était outrée de la piètre
qualité des réponses fournies quand elle
n'était tout simplement pas inexistante
et même parfois accompagnée d'une
attitude désinvolte pour ne pas dire
méprisante
certains collègues avaient déploré
l'enrobage affectif et les actes de
contrition qui fassent à de graves
ont été avérées dans les mois qui ont
suivi avaient tenu avait tenu lieu
d'expression pour les représentants du
groupe ORPEA nous devons aujourd'hui en
sortir et un an après faire le point
avec vous je vous remercie monsieur
Guillot d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation donc vous êtes le nouveau
directeur général monsieur le directeur
médical également que je salue et
j'espère que les commissaires mais aussi
nos concitoyens puisque cette réunion
est publique seront davantage satisfaits
de vos propos et de vos réponses nul
n'ignore en outre qu'au-delà de très
graves problèmes de fonctionnement mis
en lumière l'an dernier la situation
financière et la gouvernance du groupe
ORPEA ont radicalement évolué depuis
mais j'imagine que vous évoquerez avec
nous donc ces questions dans votre dans
votre propos introductif
j'indique qu'après votre intervention je
donnerai la parole représentants des
groupes politiques pour deux minutes
chacun puis aux autres députés pour deux
minutes également et vous disposerez
bien sûr d'un temps nécessaire pour
pouvoir répondre je vous passe tout de
suite la parole monsieur Guillaume
merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vous remercie
vraiment de m'avoir convié ce matin
devant la commission des affaires
sociales de l'Assemblée nationale pour
répondre à vos questions je vous
remercie d'autant plus chaleureusement
que je sais combien vos agendas sont en
ce moment extrêmement chargés
j'essaierai de répondre avec à vos
questions avec le plus de précisions et
le plus de clarté possible avec le souci
de transparence et de sincérité qui
m’anime depuis que j'ai pris la
direction d'Orpea au mois de juillet de
l'année dernière avec l'ensemble de
l'équipe de direction qui m'accompagne
et un conseil d'administration renouvelé
vous l'avez dit Madame Leprin la
Présidente nous sommes au travail depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant
si ORPEA change si hors pa a changé des
progrès gigantesques restent et doivent
encore être faits pour améliorer sur le
terrain le quotidien de nos résidents de
nos patients de leur famille de nos
collègues dans les établissements et
pour pour nous hisser à la hauteur des
attentes collectives et pour commencer
permettez-moi de prendre quelques
instants pour vous présenter mon
parcours et l'engagement qui m'a conduit
à être présent aujourd'hui devant vous
par mon histoire personnelle j'ai acquis
la conviction que réussir c'est être
utile et changer le cours des choses
j'ai fait de mon mieux pour agir
conformément à cette conviction d'abord
au service de l'État au ministère des
Finances puis en rejoignant le cabinet
du ministre de l'Équipement des
Transports et du Logement Jean-Claude
guesso à la fin des années 90 et le
combat mené à l'époque par le ministre
dans ses propres dans ses murs pour
imposer la mixité sociale dans la ville
à travers la loi SRU beaucoup marqué
j'en ai retenu que la détermination
politique et le rôle du législateur sont
essentiels pour impulser le changement
comme vous l'avez fait l'an passé et
puis j'ai rejoint Jean-Louis Befa chez
Saint-Gobain ou j'ai servi pendant une
vingtaine d'années jusqu'à devenir l'un
des directeurs généraux adjoints
Saint-Gobain m'a enseigné la rigueur et
l'organisation mais plus encore j'y ai
appris la force exceptionnelle du
collectif des femmes et des hommes qui
composent l'entreprise lorsque sa
mission est en adéquation avec nos
aspirations et nos valeurs mesdames et
messieurs les députés ils n'existent pas
à mes yeux de mission plus juste plus
noble plus utile que celle de prendre
soin des personnes les plus fragiles et
parmi eux de nos aînés comme des milieux
de français comme comme vous la lecture
du livre de Victor Castanet m'a choqué
ce que j'ai entendu et vous l'avez
rappelé ce que j'ai entendu lors des
auditions vous avez menées m'a choqué
également
les conclusions du rapport d'enquête de
la mission
IGAS IGF mon choqué à travers ses
lectures et c'est aux auditions j'ai
rapidement acquis la conviction que la
crise déclenchée par le livre était la
responsabilité d'une poignée de
dirigeants peu scrupuleux voire pour
certains crapuleux qui ont désorganisé
l'entreprise et dévoyer sa mission
d'utilité sociale ce livre m'a aussi
fait comprendre combien ce secteur était
en souffrance
mais dans le même temps j'ai aussi
acquis la conviction que les 17000
résidents et les 75 000 patients
accueillis dans nos établissements
chaque année mérité que l'on continue à
prendre soin d'eux il fallait s'engager
auprès des 26 000 salariés de
l'entreprise en France
profondément affectés par le scandale
mais qui sont restés qui sont restés
tous les jours aux côtés des plus
fragiles de nos parents de nos grands
dans nos territoires dans les 350
établissements
et quelques mois seulement après ma
prise de fonction j'y arrive j'ai
réalisé que la crise que traversée ORPEA
était plus profonde encore que celle
décrite par Victor Castanet j'ai réalisé
que le groupe était au port du dépôt de
bilan vous en avez parlé madame la
Présidente à cause d'un développement
immobilier excessif et un développement
international excessif
l'entreprise était devenue la première
foncière de santé d'Europe ce n'était
pas sa vocation et ce n'est pas ça ne
doit pas être la vocation d'entreprise
nous avons pris dans l'urgence et sous
conciliation les décisions nécessaires à
son assainissement financier l'entrée de
la Caisse des dépôts qui a été annoncée
il y a quelques jours la caisse l'entrée
la Caisse des dépôts est consignations
de MAIF de MACSF au capital d'Orpea va
nous donner les moyens financiers de
mettre en oeuvre notre plan de
refondation tel que je l'ai annoncé le
15 novembre dernier pour construire une
entreprise plus éthique une entreprise
plus humaine et une entreprise au
service des plus fragiles et de nos
aînés
je vais commencer par une entrée une
entreprise éthique depuis ma nomination
plus de 34 dirigeants ont été
sanctionnés ont quitté l'entreprise j'ai
déposé plainte contre plusieurs d'entre
eux après avoir mis en évidence des
malversations qui engagent leur
responsabilité pénale
concernant l'usage inapproprié des
dotations publiques nous nous sommes
engagés à rembourser à l'état
l'intégralité des sommes indûment
perçues sur le soin à l'Europe
et je me tiens bien évidemment à
disposition des conseils départementaux
pour faire de la même de même sur la
dépendance ces décisions étaient la
condition première pour regagner la
confiance et comme l'a dit lui-même
Victor Castanet le 25 janvier dernier
sur France Inter le système tel qu'il
existait avant a été stoppé
deuxièmement une entreprise plus humaine
lors de mes 80 visites dans nos
établissements j'ai pu constater
l'implication quotidienne de nos équipes
auprès des personnes âgées nos soignants
nos cuisiniers nos auxiliaires de vie
nos directrices et directeurs
d'établissement l'ensemble de nos
collaborateurs et collaboratrices ont
fait ce qu'il pouvait pour assurer leur
mission auprès des plus fragiles
mais pour prendre soin des plus fragiles
il faut prendre soin de nos collègues
dans les établissements
ces professionnels méritent la
reconnaissance de notre entreprise et de
la société dans son ensemble depuis
juillet ORPEA change alors qu'il
n'existait aucun dialogue social ni
négociation annuelle obligatoire aboutie
depuis 15 ans depuis 15 ans aucune aucun
dialogue social ni aucune négociation
annuelle obligatoire aboutie nous avons
signé d'ores et déjà 6 accords à
l'unanimité avec toutes les
organisations syndicales représentatives
de la branche c'est à dire celle
présente dans l'entreprise et celle qui
ne sont pas présentes dans l'entreprise
le glissement des tâches était la norme
sont pour autant que ça se traduise par
des perspectives d'évolution pour nos
collègues les moins qualifiés nous avons
décidé d'investir davantage dans la
formation initiale et continue pour leur
donner enfin de réelles perspectives
d'épanouissement et de progression dès
cette année nous allons proposer 1000
formations diplômantes auxiliaires de
vie non diplômés
les directrices ou directeurs
d'établissement
l'an dernier ne pouvait pas remplacer un
salarié absent ou changer une fenêtre
sans demander l'autorisation du ciel
nous leur avons donné des juillet
dernier l'autonomie nécessaire pour
qu'il puisse embaucher ou faire des
travaux sans demander l'autorisation la
fréquence des accidents du travail quand
je suis arrivé j'ai constaté que cette
fréquence d'accident du travail est de
50 à 100 fois super à ce que j'ai connu
dans ma vie antérieure dans l'industrie
nous avons désormais une ambition pour
la santé la sécurité de nos
collaborateurs et nous avons recruté un
directeur santé sécurité ce qui
n'existait pas donc vous voyez mesdames
et messieurs et députés dans le soin
apporté à nos collègues les choses
changent troisièmement je voulais
terminer par le plus important
évidemment nous sommes et nous devons
redevenir une entreprise au service des
plus fragiles de nos parents de nos
grands-parents
le premier critère de bien-être le
chronique critère de bien traitance
c'est le temps le temps consacré aux
personnes âgées le temps attentif le
temps de présence passé les yeux dans
les yeux la main dans la main ça veut
dire des effectifs c'est-à-dire des
effectifs suffisants pour les
accompagner et je sais que dans cet
enceinte même plusieurs d'entre vous
dans plusieurs rapports ont porté des
propositions pour instaurer un ratio
minimum d'encadrement j'y suis
personnellement très favorable depuis
l'automne nous avons recruté nous avons
recruté une à deux personnes de plus par
établissement j'en suis conscient c'est
insuffisant c'est pas assez il faut
qu'on fasse davantage
il nous faut aussi fidéliser notre
personnel pour garantir la stabilité des
équipes quand une personne différente
pas chaque jour pour faire votre
toilette c'est une atteinte à votre
intimité c'est à votre pudeur c'est une
forme de maltraitance nos résidents ont
besoin de repères et les familles
doivent pouvoir échanger avec les
personnes qui connaissent et qui suivent
leurs proches au quotidien
désormais les objectifs de nos
directrices et nos directeurs
d'établissement repose majoritairement
sur la qualité des soins et le bien-être
de nos résidents avant c'était des
critères purement financiers
le professeur Pierre crolaxalmont qui
est avec moi aujourd'hui qui a créé et
dirigé l'Institut du vieillissement des
Hospices Civils de Lyon
j'ai souhaité qu'il vienne nous
rejoindre qui viennent nous rejoindre
comme directeur médical membre du comité
de direction à mes côtés toutes
décisions dans l'entreprise
devra être prise et doit être prisé
éprise avec lui à l'aune du projet
médico-social
parce que la question de la
bientraitance renvoie aussi à celle de
l'humanité des soins et de la
compagnement le professeur Emmanuel
Hirsch nous a aussi rejoint comme
directeur de l'éthique et les travaux
ont déjà commencé depuis son arrivée sur
ce sujet pour améliorer nos pratiques
le bien-être des résidents passe aussi
par l'alimentation et ce sujet là je
sais qui vous remonte fréquemment de vos
territoires et j'y suis attaché parce
que je suis convaincu que se nourrir
c'est avant tout ça doit avant tout
rester un plaisir c'est aussi un moment
de convivialité et c'est évidemment
aussi un moment de soin nous avons
d'ores et déjà augmenté de 35 % le
budget des repas tout en privilégiant un
approvisionnement local et de saison
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés les choses ne vont
jamais assez vite je suis le premier en
interne avec les équipes à m'impatienter
certains médias vous l'avez vu récemment
ont effectué des reportages qui ont
choqué et qui ont choqué à juste titre
car ils laissent entendre que des
comportements révoltants subsistent dans
certains de nos établissements
je veux le dire très solennellement ici
un soignant ou un collègue qui manque de
respect à nos aînés n'a pas sa place
chez nous sur ces comportements ma ligne
est simple tolérance zéro
depuis notre arrivée en juillet dernier
nous changeons en repère
nous le changeons dans la transparence
et dans dialogue avec les résidents et
les patients avec les proches avec nos
collaborateurs et nos soignants mais
aussi avec la représentation nationale
et avec les pouvoirs publics le temps de
l'amélioration concrète vécu par tous
s'installe progressivement je suis
totalement conscient qu'il nous reste
énormément à faire la nouvelle équipe
avec moi s'engage et fait son maximum
pour que nos décisions portent leurs
fruits au plus vite concrètement dans
nos établissements dans nos territoires
auprès de nos aînés madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les député je vous
remercie très sincèrement du temps que
vous me consacrez et que vous m'avez
laissé pour m'exprimer devant vous le
professeur Pierre crolax allemand et
moi-même nous sommes à votre disposition
pour répondre à toutes vos questions
merci bien Monsieur le Directeur général
avant de donner la parole effectivement
aux orateurs de groupe je souscris
pleinement vos propos concernant les
professionnels de santé qui travaillent
dans dans ces établissements bien sûr
nous ne sommes pas là pour jeter
l'opprobre sur les professionnels de
santé ils ont fait ce qu'ils ont pu avec
les moyens qu'on leur avait octroyer à
l'époque très bien donc je vais tout de
suite passer la parole à Madame Annie
Vidal pour le groupe renaissance pour
deux minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur
Guillaume monsieur groslac l'effet
révélé dans le livre de Victor Castanet
tout comme les nombreux témoignages ont
provoqué une onde de chocs qui
aujourd'hui nous rappelle la nécessité
de poursuivre notre engagement auprès de
nos aînés et appelle notre vigilance
individuelle et collective pour lutter
contre toutes les formes de maltraitance
envers des personnes en situation de
vulnérabilité au-delà des situations de
maltraitance décrites c'est aussi un
système qui a été révélé visant toujours
davantage de profits au détriment des
résidents et rendant les conditions de
travail des professionnels extrêmement
difficiles merci donc messieurs de votre
présence aujourd'hui qui je l'espère
viendra restaurer l'image que vous
prédécesseurs ont laissé à la
représentation nationale et vos propos
introductifs semblent encourageant si
Victor Castanet dit que les choses
changent chez ORPEA je cite pouvez-vous
nous préciser ce que vous avez mis en
place pour lutter contre la maltraitance
envers les résidents mais aussi envers
les professionnels comment mettre un
terme à une maltraitance
institutionnelle et systémique installée
comment pensez-vous restaurer la
confiance dans vos établissements et
plus encore initié un nécessaire
processus de moralisation de tout le
secteur privé
par ailleurs et vous l'avez évoqué la
Caisse des dépôts est consignation à la
tête d'un groupement notamment de
mutuelle a fait acquisition de 50,2% des
actions de votre groupe
pardon ce qui s'inscrit dans le plan de
refondation que vous avez présenté en
novembre dernier pourriez-vous nous
indiquer en quoi ce plan permettra
d'entériner un changement définitif des
pratiques qui ont pu avoir cours dans
votre groupe pratique financières et
immobilières au détriment de la qualité
de la prise en charge des résidents et
dépourvus d'humanité dans leur
management je vous remercie merci bien
Madame la Députée Monsieur Serge Müller
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général monsieur le directeur
médical mes chers collègues j'ai été
aide-soignant en EHPAD pendant des
années je viens juste de quitter mes
fonctions pour avoir vécu des situations
compliquées je vous assure que ce métier
ne peut être réalisé sereinement quand
on n'a aucun moyen temporel pour être
attentif aux besoins des patients
assurer l'origine leur confort tout en
étant humain avec eux si on fait ce
métier c'est pour la beauté des
relations humaines qui l'engendre et le
plaisir d'aider son prochain c'est là
que réside la complexité du métier
d'aide-soignant c'est dans le fait que
ce soit un métier de cœur le cœur des
soignants d'orpa le cœur les soignants
d'or pa ont dû le mettre de côté
je cite certains témoignages de
soignants de vos cliniques on ne nous a
jamais donné le temps ni les moyens de
se concentrer sur la douche le respect
de l'hygiène le temps de toilette la
surveillance des escarres la prévention
des chutes sont altérées par le manque
de temps des personnels et la liste est
encore longue
où voyez-vous la place du coeur quand on
doit courir pour faire les toilettes
rationner le linge l'échange en laissant
les résidents dans une situation
d'hygiène catastrophique où est la
philosophie humanitude dans cette
situation celle d'aller au travail en
sachant pertinemment qu'il rentrait dans
un lieu qu'il ne connaissait plus
d'humanité mais dont la rentabilité
était reine le cœur disparaît et
l'éthique du soignant avec
tout cela engendre une forte pénibilité
au travail les taux d'incidence élevés
les troubles musculo-squelettiques et
les risques psychosociaux
Dumas disait il y a des services si
grands qu'on ne peut les payer que par
l’ingratitude je vous invite à le
prendre en compte je vous demande donc
qu'avez-vous prévu pour améliorer les
conditions de travail de vos
aides-soignants qui ont un impact
certain sur la qualité des soins des
résidents et sur leur bien-être je vous
demande enfin ce que vous pensez du
ratio soignant soigné demandés par de
nombreux syndicats je vous remercie
merci bien monsieur le député madame
Caroline Fiat pour la France insoumise
du groupe
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur vous en avez de la chance
après les scandales qui vous ont frappé
et que tout le monde a fait semblant de
découvrir l'état est finalement venu à
votre escousse et vous a promis 11 et
merveilles lors de votre domination plus
de maltraitance sur PM mais question
visent donc à sa nature l'un des points
saillants de votre maltraitance réside
dans le rationnement alimentaire or il y
a trois jours sur une chaîne
d'information continue vous déclariez il
n'y a pas de sujet de malnutrition les
moyens ont été mis en oeuvre le budget
alimentaire a été augmenté de 35%. nous
serions donc passé d'un budget de 4,20 €
par jour et un budget de 5 euros 67 ce
chiffre impressionnant de 35% ne
représente en fait qu'une maigre
augmentation du budget repas journalier
d'un euro 47 lorsqu'on met cette
augmentation en perspective de
l'inflation des produits alimentaires
je ne vous apprends pas 38%
d'augmentation pour le riz 110% pour
l'huile de tournesol 20% pour la farine
28 % pour les steaks hachés 23% pour le
beurre 18 pour les œufs j'en passe si je
corrige l'inflation sur votre
augmentation votre augmentation n'est
que des risques pensez-vous que cela va
réellement régler les problèmes de
rationnement et de dénutrition de nos
aînés concrètement combien avez-vous par
exemple augmenté les rations de viande
qui était comprise entre 40 et 60 g
autre sujet qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur le ratio
minimal de soignants par résident
soignant pas faisons fonctions s'il vous
plaît vous avez déclaré avoir des
pensées toute l'enveloppe publique
destinée aux soins pour améliorer ce
ratio alors qu'en est-il aujourd'hui
exactement et pensez-vous utiliser votre
enveloppe de dividendes pour embaucher
alors ou même la Défenseur des droits
alerte sur la situation dans les EHPAD
et où les familles continuent de porter
plainte contre vos établissements nous
attendons de vos réponses avec
impatience
très bien la parole est à Monsieur
Jérôme Guedj pour le groupe socialiste
et apparenté du Pesse
merci madame la Présidente le livre de
Victor Castanet il a posé d'abord la
question d'un acteur privé du secteur
commercial hors pa mais par
[Musique]
extension
nous sommes amenés à nous poser deux
autres types de questions au-delà du
seul cas d'orpa celle du secteur privé
commercial dans le champ des EHPAD et
celle plus largement des EHPAD
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a trois visions et
c'est sur ces trois questions que je
veux vous questionner
vous avez parlé de système crapuleux
s'agissant d'orpa vous êtes en train de
nettoyer les écuries d'ogias
il y a un enjeu pour les résidents il y
a un enjeu pour les les personnels
évidemment
il faut soutenir et les uns et les
autres
aujourd'hui dans le cadre du plan de
redressement
si j'ai bien compris avec vos nouveaux
actionnaires vous assumez le fait que
votre édit d'art va baisser
significativement c'est à dire que là
vous étiez au-dessus de la moyenne de la
rentabilité des acteurs du secteur à 26
ou 27%, vous assumez de venir plutôt
autour de 20%, est-ce que derrière ça je
me rends compte que j'ai pas avoir le
temps ça ne pose pas la question qui est
pas propre à ORPEA mais qui est propre
aussi aux acteurs du secteur qui est
celle sinon de la seule financiarisation
de ce secteur de l'hébergement des
personnes âgées mais d'avoir l'oeil rivé
sur cet indicateur et est-ce que
consubstantiellement ce type
d'indicateur n'est pas orthogonal avec
des objectifs de qualité de la prise en
charge et pour aller au bout de la
question dans les 20 secondes qui me
restent est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment dès l'instant où vous devenez
quasiment aujourd'hui un acteur un peu
hybride avec des actionnaires qui
viennent de l'économie sociale et
solidaire que c'est un secteur dans
lequel il est raisonnable d'envisager
l'objectif de dégager une rémunération
d'actionnaires et pas de se concentrer
sur un bénéfice raisonnable pour pouvoir
investir et poursuivre l'activité voilà
je m'arrête là mais j'aurais bien
d'autres questions évidemment les
saisons pour les autres monsieur
monsieur le député Monsieur François
gerdigon pour horizon et à parenté merci
madame la Présidente nous voici donc à
peu près un an après l'édition du livre
les fossoyeurs qui mettaient en lumière
les maltraitants se répéter au sein des
EHPAD du groupe ORPEA
et est annoncé la prise de contrôle d'un
groupement d'investisseurs emmené par la
Caisse des Dépôts actions que je salue
faisant de ce groupement l'actionnaire
principal avec 1,35 milliards d'euros
injectés dans le groupe privé le
ministre de l'autonomie Jean-Christophe
combe la répéter à plusieurs reprises le
secteur s'est beaucoup remis en question
depuis la sortie de cette enquête pour
mettre l'intérêt général et celui des
résidents avant les gains financiers
nous avons de toute évidence besoin des
acteurs privés pour continuer de
renforcer le secteur du Bien vieillir et
de l'autonomie surtout quand nous
connaissons les besoins liés au
vieillissement de notre de notre
population dans les années à venir
cependant nous avons également besoin un
an après ces révélations d'avoir des
acteurs privés lucratifs qui s'engagent
qui s'engagent sur des actions concrètes
pour plus de moralisation pour plus
d'attractivité des métiers du secteur
comme avec les mécanismes de partage de
la valeur finalement pour une meilleure
adéquation des objectifs et des moyens
mis en œuvre
j'ai personnellement souhaité faire de
la question du Bien Vieillir une
priorité de mon mandat je suis depuis
plusieurs mois sur le terrain pour
écouter questionner et comprendre
comment améliorer les conditions de vie
des seigneurs ainsi que les conditions
de travail de nos soignants
en ce sens ne pensez-vous pas qu'il
serait opportun que vous déclinez un
plan d'action co-construit avec
l'ensemble des catégories
professionnelles afin de partager et de
donner une vision de votre stratégie
les résultats de son plan d'action
devront être mesurées à la fin de chaque
année afin de quantifier les résultats
obtenus
ils devront être communiqués largement
afin de rassurer les résidents et leurs
familles les salariés qui ont souffert
du regard porté sur leur travail je
remercie merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général le premier février
vous annoncier l'accord trouvé avec la
Caisse des dépôts et des consignations
dans un communiqué de presse de 8 pages
8 pages qui détaillent longuement le
projet financier de la restructuration
d'orpa mais pas une seule mention de
l'humain pas un seul mot pour parler de
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
encore désastreuses du personnel
soignant ou du quotidien des personnes
hébergées traitées comme du bétail à des
fins de rentabilité les alertes se sont
multipliées ces dernières années
pourtant que ce serait-il passé si
Victor Castanet pas révélé ce qui était
déjà connu depuis bien trop longtemps
vous avez assuré sur ce plan de
refondation comportait également un
volet éthique ce volet comprend
notamment une nouvelle approche du soin
une amélioration des pratiques médicales
et éthiques ou encore le bien-être du
personnel mais nous ne pouvons cacher
notre profond scepticisme lorsque la
poursuite des bénéfices reste le
principal objectif devant le soin devant
la qualité de vie aussi bien du
personnel soignant que des personnes
hébergées
la puissance publique par le biais de la
Caisse des Dépôts va acquérir 50,2% des
parts d'orpa nous constatons qu'il
s'agit là avant tout d'une opération
financière destinée à sauver le groupe
de la faillite que tu que d'une
préoccupation de l'étain pour que le
soin au plus vulnérable redevienne un
bien public dans cette optique quel sera
le rôle concret de l'État dans le
pilotage du groupe va-t-il relever de
l'Agence nationale de participation de
l'État aux entreprises privées nous
sommes d'autant plus sceptiques car cela
ne signifie en rien le retour de
l'humain dans la politique de soins et
d'assistance aux personnes âgées dans
cette optique le groupe écologiste
s'interroge sur l'objectif de ces 1,35
milliards d'euros d'argent public
injecté dans le groupe ORPEA pouvait
nous nous garantir qu'ils seront
destinés à donner des marges de manœuvre
pour recruter du personnel améliorer les
conditions de travail et le soin ou
ORPEA va-t-elle devenir une énième
entreprise privée sous perfusion
d'argent public merci
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre Daredevil pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine lupesse
général la première question qu'on a
envie de vous poser c'est de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'il y a vraiment changé dans
le quotidien des résidentes et des
résidents qu'est-ce qui a changé du
point de vue des du personnel où en
êtes-vous des sous-effectifs du taux de
vacataire du ratio personnel résident ou
en êtes-vous des infirmiers infirmières
de nuit où on êtes-vous du versement des
salaires quel que soit les
dysfonctionnements rencontrés par le
logiciel de paye ou un êtes-vous du
recours à des faisans fonctions
qu'est-ce qui a changé du point de vue
des repas en avez-vous fini avec le
grammage ou en êtes-vous sur la quantité
et la diversité l'apport protéiné des
repas qui puissent donner l'envie aussi
encourager
l'autonomie et je rejoindrai la question
de Caroline Fiat sur les effets de
l'inflation n'ont-ils pas mangé
l'augmentation que vous avez mise sur
les repas qu'est-ce qui a changé du
point de vue de l'encadrement
de la culture et de la pratique des
directeurs nationaux et régionaux dont
un certain nombre sont quand même restés
en poste qu'en est-il de l'autonomie des
directeurs d'établissements enfin qu'en
est-il aussi de l'encadrement des
auxiliaires de vie en VAE dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure qui en réalité à ma
connaissance n'ont pas toujours
d'encadrement
qu'en est-il également des travaux
nécessaires dans les établissements qui
qui le demandent qu'en est-il des tarifs
j'ai vu des augmentations qui m'ont un
peu surpris dans certains établissements
est-ce que vous avez des explications
là-dessus et enfin quels sont les
objectifs financiers de moyen terme qui
vous ont été fixés et pouvez nous vous
nous préciser les contours de votre but
lucratif si tenter que ce but est encore
un sens
merci bien alors nous avons six
questions mais je vais passer la parole
à Monsieur directeur général pour des
éléments de réponse et ceci permettra
peut-être voilà à Madame Fiat de vous
entendre monsieur directeur général
puisqu'elle s'excuse elle devra partir
puisqu'elle doit présider voilà la
séance au sein des missiles voilà merci
souhaitez-vous madame le Président que
je commence par répondre à Madame Fiat
sur Madame la Députée sur le
rationnement alimentaire sur la question
l'alimentaire qui a une question
extrêmement fondamentale parce que c'est
un moment
fondamental de la vie de nos patients
dans nos EHPAD ça doit être je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure ça doit être vraiment un
moment de plaisir un moment de joie et
nous nous attachons à ce que ce soit le
cas je n'ai pas dit qu'il y avait pas de
malnutrition vous savez que 50% des
personnes qui rentrent dans nos
établissements sont en état de malnutrie
déjà et donc nous nous attachons à faire
améliorer cette situation et d'ailleurs
deux tiers des situations de
malnutrition ont disparu après un an
parce que c'est un soin
on a comme je vous l'ai dit on a
augmenté de 35% le budget alimentaire
clairement vous l'avez noté il y a de
l'inflation donc c'est 35% tiennent
compte de l'inflation mais l'inflation
qu'on constate de façon générale et
plutôt de l'ordre d'une quinzaine de
pour cent donc nous avons fait des
efforts réels sur sur ces aspects après
je sais pas je suis pas en train de vous
dire que tout est résolu j'ai pas de
baguette magique je suis pas capable de
tout changer en six mois une situation
qui était très difficile quand je l'ai
trouvé mais je peux vous garantir que
l'alimentation est un est un sujet
fondamental et qui passe aussi par un
point qui est majeur qui est la
formation de nos chefs la formation de
nos chefs au quotidien pour qu'il
s'adapte puis qu'il est adapté ils ont
aujourd'hui liberté pour dépasser leur
budget ajuster comme ils le veulent les
si quelqu'un un homme patient un
non-résidents veut avoir plus à manger
il suffit qu'il le demande il y a pas de
il y a pas de sujet aujourd'hui c'est
très clair
après on s'engagera à moi je vous invite
madame Fiat à venir dans nos
établissements et à venir manger comme
vous tous je vous invite tous vous nous
aiderez vous nous aiderez à nous faire
un retour et à nous à nous donner des
éléments pour continuer à progresser
parce que clairement nous avons un
travail gigantesque à faire sur ce plan
sur le ratio soignant soigné sur le
ratio soignant soigné il y a vous avez
été plusieurs à poser cette question
c'est clairement un point important
comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure je
moi je suis favorable à ce que on
augmente et on contrôle ce ratio j'ai je
j'y suis extrêmement favorable et nous
mettrons les moyens en face si
nécessaire ce ratio là ce qui était tôt
dans le cadrement entre le début de
l'année 2022 et la fin 2022 en j'étais
là depuis quatre mois il a augmenté de
10% c'est pas encore assez je voulais
dit ça représente un à personne par
établissement parce qu'on a des
difficultés toujours agrumes mais c'est
vraiment important qu'on le fasse je
vais reprendre
et alors mon dernier point que vous et
que j'avais oublié sur les dividendes
clairement compte tenu notre situation
financière nous allons pas verser des
dividendes pendant plusieurs années et
tous les moyens que nous allons dégager
notamment en recentrant l'entreprise sur
le soin et l'accompagnement et en étant
plus une foncière c'est à dire en
sortant du développement international à
outrance en sortant des investissements
immobiliers fait sur fonds propres nous
allons les remettre dans le soin et
l'accompagnement
j'espère madame la députée Fiat que j'ai
répondu à vos questions
madame la député Vidal
sur les sujets de lutte contre les
maltraitances qui concernent je
comprends à la fois les professionnels
et les résidents sur des professionnels
clairement
la situation que nous avons trouvé était
extrêmement difficile vous vous le savez
dès mon arrivée nous avons repris le
dialogue avec les partenaires sociaux de
façon extrêmement intense puisque après
15 ans sans accord social sans Nao signé
nous avons désormais eu 6 accords signés
à l'unanimité avec évidemment les
représentants du personnel qui étaient
internes et qui ont été élus par le
personnel mais aussi ceux qui étaient à
l'extérieur parce que c'était important
de recréer
je dirais un collectif de dialogues
sociales beaucoup plus large que
seulement uniquement avec l'entreprise
dans ces accords il y a eu des accords
qui ont eu vocation à organiser
le dialogue social et d'autres à donner
des augmentations de salaires donc nous
avons prévu notamment sur cleanéa des
augmentations salaires et la mise en
place d'un treizième mois qui est
fondamental
parce que ça permet de retenir mieux les
personnels et la rétention est un sujet
fondamental comme je vous l'ai dit tout
à l'heure avoir en permanence du
personnel qui est pas le même face à un
résident pour moi je considère que c'est
une forme de maltraitance peut-être que
Pierre tu veux sur la maltraitance
elle-même pour nos résidents faire une
petite présentation de ce que tu fais et
puis répondre sur ce point
merci Laurent mesdames et messieurs les
députés
les députés bonjour
avant de répondre précisément à cette
question permettez-moi quelques mots
introductifs qui qui illustrent ma
démarche pour rejoindre ce groupe ce
groupe horaire c'est d'abord un honneur
d'être devant vous et de pouvoir
débattre de l'aide à la dépendance des
associés au grand âge
et avant d'accepter le poste de
directeur médical du groupe ORPEA sachez
que j'ai lu deux fois le livre de Victor
Castanet et comme de nombreux lecteurs
j'ai été profondément bouleversé par
l'histoire de ces personnes qui ont
souffert au terme de leur vie dans le
contexte de leur hébergement maison de
retraite
j'ai été très choqué par les
malversations atroce d'une équipe
dirigeante cynique
c'est détournements ont affaibli les
ressources des établissements
venant aggraver d'une part les grandes
difficultés du secteur le défaut de
valorisation des métiers d'attractivité
et la très grande complexité d'autre
part des soins à apporter à nos aînés
les plus fragiles souvent en grande
dépendance la grande complexité de la
médecine associée au vieillissement et à
la dépendance
je me suis dit alors que je pouvais
modestement apporter mon export mon
expérience acquise au sein du CHU de
Lyon 2e CHU de France au sein de
l'Institut du vieillissement qui a
organisé des parcours intégrés depuis le
domicile les secteurs ambulatoires les
hospitalisations mais jusqu'à
l'hébergement en unité de soin de longue
durée et aider sur tous les équipes
soignantes à apporter les meilleurs
soins
et enfin j'ai été convaincu par la
profonde sincérité de la nouvelle équipe
dirigeant du groupe emmené par Laurent
Guillot à la tête de la direction
générale et Guillaume Pepy à la tête du
conseil d'administration j'ai perçu leur
engagement profond pour remettre le
projet médico-soignant au cœur des
préoccupations de l'entreprise et bien
au-delà j'espère et dès l'ensemble du
secteur qui sert cette grande cause
alors pour ce qui concerne la
maltraitance qui est le sujet un des
principes des principaux sujets qui nous
qui nous préoccupent
il faut rappeler vous le savez que
la mission de soins et d'accompagnement
des équipes exigent la bien traitance et
la bienveillance c'est par essence le
cœur du métier un aide-soignant une
aide-soignante qui se lève le matin
vient travailler pour pour être
bienveillant pour être bien traitante
c'est notre devoir en tant que encadrant
de de d'organiser les conditions pour
que c'était de soignante cette
infirmière puisse puisse être bien
traitante et bienveillante et c'est
notre devoir de
prévenir cette maltraitance de la
dépister de la détecter et de l'appareil
de la traiter d'un point de vue
organisationnel et puis il faut savoir
de quoi on parle quand on parle de
maltraitance madame Vidal vous le savez
très bien nous le partageons
là les petits gestes quotidiens des
gestes trop rapides des gestes
techniques
parfois peu enveloppés d'empathie
parfois peu accompagnés de considération
de l'humain avec une concentration sur
le sur ce caractère technique du geste
soignant et bien c'est de la
maltraitance c'est de la maltraitance et
c'est pour ça que je l'ai déjà dit pour
moi le risque de maltraitance n'est
jamais considéré comme nul c'est une
vigilance permanente du quotidien et
puis la maltraitance direct la
maltraitance volontaire est
exceptionnelle elle relève de de cas
très particuliers pour lesquels nous
sommes très vigilants et qui doivent
faire l'objet de sanction disciplinaire
alors en pratique que faisons-nous avec
Emmanuel Hirsch le professeur Emmanuel
Hyères je nous organisons une démarche
éthique et bien traitance qui va aller
jusque dans les établissements au plus
près des équipes en organisant des
cellules interdisciplinaires
psychologue directeur mais aussi
aide-soignant infirmier des cellules qui
vont veiller à ce que chaque cas qui
soulève une question éthique
puisse relever d'une concertation
interdisciplinaire à l'échelle de
l'établissement mais aussi à l'échelle
de la région et à l'échelle du comité
d'orientation éthique organise Emmanuel
Hirsch nous renforçons nous accélérons
la formation des référents bien
traitants s'il y en a près de 300 formé
dans le dans le groupe 298 exactement à
ce jour et il faut accélérer ça et nous
espérons pouvoir former les deux
référents bien traitants par
rétablissement d'ici quelques mois donc
voilà des actions très précises pour nos
établissements
merci merci Pierre c'est d'être très
clair
monsieur le député je vais remettre mes
lunettes parce que je vous vois pas
merci le député
mes problèmes de vue ça n'a rien à voir
Monsieur le Député Müller je suis je
suis je suis mais complètement d'accord
avec votre intervention sur le temps
nécessaire pour pour les soignants et
qui est
source involontaire de leur part de
parfois de maltraitance et qu'il faut
complètement combattre c'est pour ça que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure des
premiers points c'est d'améliorer le
taux d'encadrement et comme je voulais
également dit je pense que votre aide
collective est bienvenu en la matière
pour que on l'inscrive et puis après
notre travail ce sera de former trouver
embaucher parce que c'est un secteur
également en tension qui est qui est
difficile sur les conditions de travail
eux-mêmes
je dois dire que moi j'ai été choqué par
les taux de fréquence d'accident avec
arrêt dans ce secteur de façon générale
je viens d'un monde de l'industrie où
les taux de fréquences d'accidents avec
arrêt sont autour de 0,5 1 c'est des
taux de fréquence normaux et quand on
dépasse ça on s'inquiète de ce qui se
passe dans une usine nous sommes dans le
secteur du soin ou c'est encore plus
important d'être en sécurité j'allais
dire et nous avons des taux de
fréquences d'accidents de 40 à 50
c'est-à-dire 100 fois plus c'est
complètement inacceptable donc on a j'ai
fait venir pour rejoindre notre équipe
un directeur santé sécurité et on est en
train de mettre en place des programmes
ça concerne le port des chaussures ça
concerne les gants ça concerne les
petits équipements ça concerne
évidemment il y a énormément de mal de
dos donc ça concerne aussi des
porte-charges qu'il faut mettre et qu'il
faut avoir et un taux d'équipement de
nos de nos maisons qu'il faut mettre en
place c'est
c'est un travail gigantesque que je l'ai
fait dans mon dans ma vie précédente ça
prend des années et des années et des
années mais il faut l'engager pour que
nos collaborateurs travaillent le
premier devoir qu'on a envisager nos
collaborateurs c'est qu'il rentre chez
eux en bonne santé le soir quand ils ont
fait leur journée de travail
sur leur condition de travail il faut
parler aussi rémunération c'est très
clairement un angle sur lequel nous
allons travailler fidélisation
la mutuelle n'est pas au niveau où elle
devrait être donc il y a énormément de
chantiers sur je dirais le côté
financier qui est un côté qu'il faut pas
qu'il faut pas éluder et puis la
formation elle-même
nous allons nous avons prévu un budget
de 16 millions d'euros de formation pour
l'année qui vient qui est une
augmentation en fait un de ces millions
c'est tout à fait significatif et
c'est vraiment un axe de travail
important
monsieur monsieur le député Guedj et est
revenu sur nos objectifs financiers en
notant bien d'ailleurs que nos ambitions
dans le cadre du plan de refondation que
j'ai proposé nos ambitions sont bien
moindres que celles qui étaient par le
passé
ça c'est important parce que en fait ça
souligne que notre œil
n'est pas rivé sur l'indicateur de
rentabilité il est plutôt rivé sur les
EIG les événements indésirables graves
combien nous en avons et je le reçois
cet indicateur toutes les semaines et je
le regarde toutes les semaines et je
fais un débriefing sur les points pour
savoir ce qui se passe et comment on
peut le corriger sur le taux
d'encadrement sur la rotation du
personnel c'est ça les indicateurs sur
lesquels nos yeux ne sont rivés après il
faut pas se tromper nous sommes et nous
restons une entreprise à but lucratif
mais je suis complètement persuadé qu'on
peut être à la fois une entreprise du
secteur lucratif et faire formidable
bien son travail et c'est ça mon
ambition
un monsieur monsieur Garnier gonfle
c'était
votre question portée sur le plan
d'action co-construit avec nos
collaborateurs en fait ce plan que j'ai
proposé de 15 novembre il a largement
été conçu avec nos collègues en interne
mais surtout et beaucoup avec les
remontées que nous avions eu lors des
états généraux que nous avons fait au
printemps et que nous avons continué
entre le printemps et l'automne et donc
avec plus de 1700 pages de documents
d'information de commentaires parfois
extrêmement touchant
notamment
on avait la discussion sur les
conditions de travail de nos collègues
sur la difficulté qu'ils avaient à ne
pas être maltraitant compte tenu des
pauvres des moyens qu'ils avaient et
donc ce plan de refondation qu'on a
construit qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a
présenté il s'inspire largement des
discussions que nous avons eues avec eux
il a été communiqué il y a des objectifs
et nous allons communiquer de façon
extrêmement régulière et si vous le
souhaitez je vous communiquerai avec
vous de façon directe sur ce point
monsieur le député péta vie vous êtes
vous avez souligné
la densité des communiqués de de presse
financières que que nous avons lorsqu'on
a annoncé
le projet avec la Caisse des dépôts est
consignations je suis le premier croyez
bien je suis premier à le regretter mais
ce sont des des informations que je suis
obligé de donner au marché qui ne
représente pas du tout ce qu'on veut
faire ce qu'on veut faire et si vous
prenez le plan de refondation qu'on a
proposé qu'on a présenté le 15 novembre
dernier il doit y avoir allez une
vingtaine de pages qui concernent les
éléments financiers et sans 150 pages
sur le soin sur nos collègues sur nos
collaborateurs sur et la priorité numéro
un c'est mon collègue parce que c'est
eux qui font le travail au quotidien
auprès de nos patients nos résidents et
c'est eux qui sont les vrais
responsable de la continuité et de
l'entreprise et c'est eux la valeur de
l'entreprise
le rôle concret de l'état non
l'entreprise ne dépendra pas de l'Agence
des participations de l'État elle
dépendent directement de la Caisse des
dépôts et consignations qui est une part
nous serons donc une participation de
une des participations de la Caisse des
dépôts et consignations la caisse sera
évidemment représentée au conseil de
même que seront représentés les
mutuelles maifs et MACSF et c'est devant
le conseil que nous
présenterons régulièrement la stratégie
avant de de l'expliquer encore une fois
comme je l'ai indiqué dans ma réponse au
député Guedj l'objectif que nous avons
de profiter et bien moindre que celui
que nous avions par le passé le travail
et la priorité ce sont
nos collègues et nos et nos patients non
résidents avant avant tout mes objectifs
personnels le premier de mes objectifs
financier cette fois-ci mon bonus si
vous voulez le dire comme ça et tu as
40% sur le bien-être et les résidents
30% sur des objectifs généraux
qualitatifs de la mise en place du plan
d'action et uniquement 30% sur le niveau
financier donc vous voyez nous avons
rééquilibré et c'est normal et c'est
logique et c'est le au profit des
patients et des résidents les objectifs
de l'entreprise
j'avais une question à des questions
après
de Monsieur dareyville qu'est-ce qui a
changé alors que j'ai une question il y
avait énormément de questions je vais
essayer de les passer tout en revue vous
me permettre vous me pardonnerez
j'espère si j'en oublie une qu'est-ce
qui a changé sur le personnel
dialogue social beaucoup plus intense
qui conduisent à des pour eux la
première fois dans les dernières
quinzaine d'années des négociations
annuelles obligatoires abouties et donc
des augmentations de salaire la mise en
place d'un 13ème mois une réflexion qui
est engagée sur les mutuelles énormément
enfin j'allais dire on remet
on fait beaucoup de choses mais la
vérité c'est qu'on remet l'entreprise
dans une démarche normale après on
pourra faire du progrès incrémental
encore là on en est encore à recréer les
basiques et ça va pas assez vite et on
essaye de faire tout notre possible on a
amélioré le ratio d'encadrement de 10%
sur les infirmières de nuit
on n'a pas d'infirmière de nuit toutes
les nuits on a comme c'est on a un
système d'astreinte dans nos
établissements et
c'est un point c'est un point
extrêmement important
on a redonné beaucoup d'autonomie à nos
collègues dans les établissements ils
peuvent embaucher ils peuvent faire des
dépenses de réparation comme je vous
l'ai dit les les embauches étaient
soumis à l'approbation du siège
historiquement maintenant nos collègues
peuvent embaucher directement et ils
doivent parce que c'est localement qu'on
trouve les ressources et localement
qu'on trouve les personnes et les
aides-soignants et les auxiliaires de
vie pour pour venir nous aider sur les
sur les VAE nous allons proposer à nos
à la fois VAE et en proie donc sur les
formations nous allons proposer 1000
formations à nos auxiliaires de vie qui
veulent se former qui veulent venir être
soignant 1000 formations sur l'année
la culture vous avez parlé de la culture
la culture échange mais elle change très
lentement c'est très difficile quand
vous avez été habitué à recevoir des
ordres et à ne faire que obéir et à être
vivre dans sa culture de la peur c'est
très difficile de de changer du jour au
lendemain donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose qu'on travaille avec les équipes
pour leur dire qu'elles peuvent elles
ont droit je leur fais confiance c'est
un acte de confiance que je leur ai
donné mais il faut qu'elle saisisse
cette opportunité et je les appelle à
chaque fois que je les ai je les appelle
à saisir cette opportunité sur les
tarifs où ils nous augmentons nos tarifs
notre inflation et ce problème là je le
partage avec les EHPAD public et les
EHPAD associatifs l'inflation à laquelle
nous faisons tous face dans tout le
secteur il est plutôt de l'ordre de 9 à
10%, c'est gigantesque parce que c'est
de l'inflation évidemment sur les
salaires et c'est normal parce que les
salaires sont faibles et et nos
personnels sont touchés par l'inflation
des de alimentaire l'inflation
énergétique et donc ils ont besoin qu'on
augmente leur rémunération on est touché
par l'inflation de la nourriture on est
touché par l'inflation de l'énergie même
si il y a un bouclier fiscal un bouclier
pardon pas fiscal un bouclier
énergétique qui nous permet d'absorber
une partie de cette augmentation il en
reste une paramètre charge et donc notre
inflation globale elle est très
importante elle est autour de 9 à 10% et
c'est pour ça que je comprends
totalement les EHPAD public et les EHPAD
associatifs qui sont dans une situation
réellement dans une situation très
difficile et qui va falloir donc il va
falloir s'occuper mais nous avons cette
situation aussi et donc nous devons
augmenter malheureusement nos tarifs
dans des proportions qui sont parfois
difficiles j'en ai complètement
complètement conscience
je crois que j'ai terminé les questions
de ce premier tour très bien Monsieur le
Directeur Général donc nous allons
poursuivre avec toute une série de
questions j'en ai pour l'instant 13
alors je passe tout de suite la parole
pour deux minutes mes chers collègues à
Erica lozet
je vous donne le micro
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général messieurs nous sommes
évidemment très intéressés de pouvoir
échanger avec vous ce matin avant de
vous poser ma question je voudrais vous
dire que nous avons envie de vous faire
confiance en aïveté bien évidemment une
crise si profonde soit elle et c'est le
cas évidemment pour Europa est toujours
une opportunité de progrès et les
éléments de réponse que vous venez
d'apporter aux questions de mes
collègues vont dans ce sens vous savez
que vous êtes scruté de très près vous
êtes marqué à la culotte si je puis dire
et que vous n'avez pas le droit à
l'erreur votre responsabilité est énorme
vous le savez bien entendu la pression
est donc très forte sur le roue ORPEA la
réussite est impérative
ma question est la suivante bien que
vous ayez témoigné une certaine
satisfaction envers l'entrée majoritaire
de la Caisse des dépôts et des
consignations au capital d'Orpea dans
les colonnes de France Info le 1er
février dernier il semblerait qu'en
coulisse si je puis dire cette solution
n'était pas celle que vous auriez
privilégié on a pu entendre ici et là
que vous puissiez plutôt pour une
solution orientée vers des fonds
minoritaires aussi Monsieur le Directeur
Général et sauf si toutes vos réserves
sont désormais balayées pourriez-vous
nous apporter des éclairages que vous
jugerez nécessaire sur d'éventuelles
doutes que vous auriez pu avoir quant au
rachat de repas par la Caisse des dépôts
et des consignations et le cas échéant
qu'elles auraient été vos préconisations
de sauvetage du groupe je vous remercie
merci bien Monsieur Thierry frappé
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général monsieur le directeur
médical la situation de nos aînés en
France anime les débats parlementaires
mais aussi rythme la vie de famille avec
l'abandon par le gouvernement de la loi
grandtage ce sont plus de 500000
personnes
âgées actuellement qui réside sous
responsabilité des pâtes comme dans
votre groupe voici maintenant 12 mois
que le scandale hors pa a éclaté 12 mois
que votre entreprise fait couler de
l'encre sur l'ensemble des journaux et
anime le débat après ces nombreux mois
cette longue traversée du désert vous
avez perdu la confiance de nos
concitoyens des familles et de nombreux
politiques nous ne demandons qu'à vous
l'accorder mais nous avons besoin de
précision que dire que faire
notre groupe a proposé une visite au
sein des établissements de santé de
façon inopinée dans un but d'évaluation
in situ qu'en pensez-vous
de plus nous découvrons nombreuses
informations au fil des jours c'est le
code dernièrement avec l'annonce de la
Caisse des Dépôts entrant au capital de
l'entreprise en devenant actionnaire
majoritaire avec la MAIF et la MACSF
pour une durée imprécise estimée
actuellement à 5 ans mais question sont
les suivantes cette caisse des dépôts
a-t-elle vocation à rester actionnaire
majoritaire sur le long terme enfin
pouvez-vous nous expliquer quels moyens
seront mis en œuvre pour retrouver la
confiance de l'opinion publique je vous
remercie
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Didier Martin
merci madame la Présidente
[Musique]
rassurer les familles je crois que votre
présence devant nous et publiquement
aussi peut les rassurer parce que vous
êtes l'élite de la nation en quelque
sorte un expo qui a fait une brillante
carrière dans l'administration puis dans
l'industrie l'élite de l'université
française aussi que vous représentez à
travers vous je veux pas vous flatter en
disant ça mais ça rassure et puis les
pépites et puis la CDC tout ça là on
prend la mesure à la tête mais sur le
terrain il s'agit aussi de rassurer très
concrètement moi en Côte-d'Or un seul
établissement ORPEA nous avons en 2022
traversé une période où il n'y avait
plus de direction plus de médecins
coordonnateurs plus d'infirmières corps
de natrices c'était absolument
une catastrophe et les familles se sont
tournées très naturellement vers nous
entre autres
parce qu'il n'avait aucune aucun
interlocuteur par rapport à ce qui se
passait vraiment les équipes ont été
abandonnées sur le terrain j'espère que
le cas de Messigny en Côte-d'Or n'est
pas trop répété sur le territoire mais
il faut rassurer deuxièmement il s'agit
transformer le scandale Europa
le sortir cette entreprise des abîmes
ont été tombés et voués aux gimoni pour
en faire un exemple un exemple pour vous
pour votre entreprise pour la pérennité
de la pérennité d'entreprise mais aussi
pour tout le secteur parce que le
secteur était traumatisé par le scandale
européen donc vous nous annoncez un plan
c'est bien il s'agit d'améliorer le
service au plus vulnérable le management
les salariés les conditions de travail
le dialogue social la gestion saine sans
la course au profit et préparer ce
virage de l'évolution démographique dans
notre pays de façon saine ma question
elle est simple vous l'avez évoqué
brièvement vous allez rembourser l'État
et rembourser des conseils
départementaux comment quelle méthode
allez vous suivre comment allez-vous
estimer cette dette et comment le frérot
savoir en général quel sera votre
communication merci bien monsieur le
député la parole est à Monsieur Didier
Le Gac
merci madame la Présidente m'écouter ma
question dans le même sens alors moi je
suis élu de Bretagne en Bretagne il y a
très peu d'établissements privés il y a
pas de de établissement du groupe ORPEA
nous avons quasi essentiellement que des
EHPAD public ou associatifs bien ma
question le groupe ORPEA a accepté de
rembourser à la CNSM que nationale de
solidarité pour l'autonomie les 55,8
millions d'euros d'argent public réclamé
au titre des mauvaises pratiques passées
au lieu des 25,7 millions envisagés la
différence 30 millions
correspondrait à la rémunération de
salariés du groupe c'est ce que vous
avez déclaré faisant fonction
d'aide-soignant sans en avoir la
qualification alors vous avez répondu en
partie à ma question tout à l'heure par
la voix de la VAE car je voulais savoir
quels étaient justement les actions
concrètes que le groupe ORPEA envisagé
de prendre notamment pour aider à
accompagner son personnel auxiliaire de
vie bon vous avez parlé de VAE mais
essayer de développer quand même parce
qu'elle avait eu c'est des formations
externes rendez-vous en interne
qu'est-ce que vous mettez comme action
pour justifier cette différence de de 30
millions d'euros et puis plus largement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler un
peu de votre nouvelle ligne politique RH
notamment en matière d'apprentissage ou
de recrutement voilà merci Monsieur
merci bien la parole est à Monsieur
Freddy certain merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Directeur Général
monsieur le directeur médical
permettez-moi d'introduire mes propos en
cliquant Simone de Beauvoir qui en 1970
écrivait que l'on connaît le degré de
civilisation d'une société à la place
qu'elle accorde à ces personnes âgées et
clairement l'affaire qui concerne votre
groupe a mis en lumière tous les
dysfonctionnements de notre société face
à la prise en charge du vieillissement
de nos aînés alors oui comme mes
collègues l'ont appelé cette affaire à
choqué et ému la France entière et a
raison j'en retire toutefois aussi un
autre enseignement ce sujet assume
mobilisé tant l'opinion publique que
l'opinion politique et l'accompagnement
des personnes âgées a enfin été mise en
lumière que ce soit au domicile qu'en
établissement spécialisé
en 2019 la Direction de la recherche des
études et de l'évaluation des
statistiques dénombrées 770 000 places
réparties dans 11000 structures
d'hébergement pour personnes âgées les
EHPAD représentaient alors 70% des
districtures d'hébergement mais
aujourd'hui notre population vieillit la
part des 75 ans devrait passer à 14,6%
de la population contre 9,1% en 2015 cet
enjeu est donc majeur pour nous
serions-nous en mesure d'apporter aux
résidents tout le confort et le respect
qu'il mérite au personnel encadrant et
soignants les moyens pour faire leur
métier dignement et aux familles la
confiance en ces structures pour prendre
soin de leurs proches nous députés
Renaissance nous porterons d'ici cet été
la proposition de loi visant à bâtir une
société du Bien vieillir en France et je
ne doute pas que nous pourrons compter
sur l'ensemble des collègues ici
présents pour adopter nos mesures qui
visent à répondre pleinement à ces
questions
quant à votre groupe vous l'annonciez la
Caisse des dépôts est consignation
annoncée qu'elle allait en faire
l'acquisition de
50,2%. je salue ici l'arrivée de cet
acteur de votre capital ramenant ainsi
la confiance
si nous comprenons bien là Caisse des
Dépôts va avant tout éviter de nouvelles
situations maltraitance c'est mettre en
œuvre des objectifs de qualité et nous
pouvons que le salut dans ce cadre
Monsieur le Directeur Général
envisagez-vous de faire évoluer les
statuts de votre entreprise afin que
celle-ci devienne une entreprise à
mission
par ailleurs comme votre groupe a
présenté un plan refondation le 15
novembre dernier celui-ci laisse
entendre un certain nombre d'évolution
or je lisais l'interview de Victor
Castanet l'auteur des fossoyeurs à La
Voix du Nord et il évoquait la présence
encore de directeur et directrice est en
mise en cause le fait que vous auriez
conservé les mêmes fournisseurs
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général merci de venir ici
pour nous parler de ce de ce
rétablissement de confiance on avait eu
l'occasion de se rencontrer lors d'un
conflit dur en décembre dernier avec
d'autres collègues ici de la Commission
à faire sociale monsieur Delaporte
monsieur Ruffin de vos salariés de votre
filiale d'aide à domicile et j'avais pu
effectivement par moi-même un constater
votre volonté sincère et de rétablir le
dialogue social à travers des NAO et
d'autres d'autres éléments tout aussi
importants moi j'aimerais revenir sur
une problématique qui a été deux choses
une problématique qui a été soulevée par
par le collègue Jérôme Guedj sur les
marges opérationnelles vous avez
effectivement annoncé dans vos
communications financières que vous
souhaitiez passer de 26% à une vingtaine
de pour cent mais ma question c'est
est-ce que même 20%
restent
reste possible en fait pour être
compatible avec la volonté et
d'améliorer la qualité de vie de vos
résidences et les conditions de travail
et la qualité de vie vos salariés tout
en maintenant une politique
d'investissement dans les équipements et
puis j'avais une question plus précise
sur la situation des dominomes j'ai eu
l'occasion de les rencontrer il y a
trois semaines
et elles m'ont fait part d'un sujet mais
qui ne concerne pas que les salariés
Domidom mais l'ensemble des salariés qui
se déplacent à domicile c'est la
question des transports or indemnités
kilométrique puisque ça concerne à la
fois
le temps de transport comptabilisé par
l'employeur entre chaque bénéficiaire
qui prend pas suffisamment le temps
effectif passé dans les transports et
entre chaque patient et Assala s'ajoute
la distance parfois importante entre le
domicile de l'aide-soignante et celui de
son trop bénéficiaire ce qui se traduit
par moins de temps passé auprès du
bénéficiaire et aussi un coût important
porté par le salarié dans un contexte de
hausse des prix du carburant et donc
c'était aussi cette des questions qui
revenait régulièrement chez vos salariés
mais également dans ce secteur y compris
dans le secteur associatif merci
Monsieur le Directeur Général merci
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Emmanuel Tachet de lagerie
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Général monsieur le directeur
médical chers collègues le groupe Orphea
a trahi la confiance et souvent brisé la
vie de milliers de famille et de
pensionnaires désirant tout simplement
passer leur vieux jours de manière
paisible digne et en sécurité les soins
apportés à nos aînés sont un enjeu de
civilisation ce scandale nous oblige et
nous alerte la marchandisation et la
logique de rentabilité détruit tout et
avilie jusqu'à notre humanité nous
pouvons regretter par ailleurs que le
gouvernement est renoncé un véritable
politique pour nos aînés en enterrant
2021 la loi grand âge et autonomie il
est également désolé que la proposition
portée par le rassemblement national
visant à donner un droit de visite au
parlementaire dans les établissements
sociaux et médico-sociaux aient été
écartés par pure dogmatisme et
sectarisme inévitable je salue l'entrée
au capital majoritaire de la Caisse des
Dépôts donnant l'espoir de la fin d'une
marche d'une marchandisation débridée et
d'un meilleur contrôle de vos
établissements mais ceci n'est toutefois
pas un chèque en blanc
de plus l'annonce d'un lieu disant pour
nos aînés et de la baisse future de la
rémunisation des actionnaires a provoqué
l'effondrement de deux tiers de valeur
de la valeur boursière d'orpa depuis la
semaine dernière donc acte ainsi
pensez-vous sincèrement qu'il est
possible d'allier dignité humaine avec
la logique de rentabilité de lucre qui
est la vôtre notamment à Miramas dans ma
circonscription enfin il est regrettable
que les EHPAD associatifs non lucratifs
confrontés à des difficultés majeures et
réclamer des investissements publics
comparables à se développer pour sauver
ORPEA vainement et au profit d'une
structure qui s'est gavée sur la fin de
vie quelle mesure concrète va prendre
leur pa ou votre direction pour nous
assurer définitivement que la dignité de
nos aînés est assurée et que les
travailleurs puissent assurer leur
fonction dans des conditions normales je
vous remercie
si bien je prends une dernière question
parce que Monsieur Laurent Guillot
souhaite répondre déjà à cette deuxième
salle de question donc je prends comme
on en a assez je fais la moitié donc je
prends la 8e question c'est Nicole dubré
Chirat madame la député vous avez la
parole oui merci madame la Présidente
merci messieurs pour vos propos
excusez-moi en retard donc peut-être
avez-vous déjà répondu à certaines
questions le vieillissement de la
population et la perte d'autonomie
constitue aujourd'hui l'une des
principales préoccupations des Français
pour leur famille il est primordial de
mettre en place une stratégie de
prévention de la perte d'autonomie tant
au niveau national que territorial de
garantir à chacun un hébergement ainsi
que des prestations de qualité et
accessibles et de lutter contre toutes
les formes de maltraitance c'est l'objet
des réflexions que nous menons afin de
bâtir la société du Bien vieillir en
France depuis un an vos établissements
ont été mis en cause et de nombreux
établissements de votre groupe on fait
l'objet d'un contrôle quelle est la
teneur de ces contrôles prennent-ils la
forme dans leur grande partie d'un envoi
juste de pièces administratives afin de
garantir une prise en charge des
personnes âgées qui ont besoin d'aide et
de soins au quotidien de répondre au
souci des familles et d'améliorer les
conditions de travail du personnel et de
renforcer l'attractivité des métiers et
de vous favorable la mise en place d'un
ratio minimal de soignants par résidant
et à quel taux d'autre part une étude
note que une personne sur deux en
établissement et dénutri ou à risque de
dénutrition et que les besoins
caloriques ou protéiques de 80% des
résidents n'est pas satisfait quelles
actions menez-vous pour améliorer la
nutrition des résidents de vos
établissements et j'ai une question pour
ma collègue Monique ibora le 1er janvier
2023 la Caisse des Dépôts éconiation a
annonçait qu'à aller faire l'acquisition
de 50,2% des actions du groupe ORPEA va
donc bénéficier d'argent public le 7
février à 14h l'action d'Orpea ce
monnaie à 2,20 en hausse sur la journée
de plus
5,4%. le jour de l'annonce de l'accord
avec la Caisse des dépôts et les monter
à 5,28 euros on peut supposer donc que
les actionnaires d'orpa se félicitent de
l'intervention
est-ce le cas d'autre part pensez-vous
devoir modifier le statut de votre
entreprise au moins en France
l'actionnaire principal étant public
enfin qu'est-ce qui devrait changer dans
votre organisation dans les EHPAD pour
lutter contre la maltraitance qui est
dénoncée dans le livre de Castanet très
bien j'avoue qu'il y avait quand même
des redites puisque Monsieur le
Directeur Général avait déjà répondu à
certaines de vos questions mais bon vous
avez la parole monsieur Monsieur le
Directeur Général
merci madame la Présidente et merci
monsieur le député à l'oser pour votre
marque de confiance
j'ai envie de vous répondre que la
confiance n'exclut pas le contrôle et
donc je je suis extrêmement et je
continue comme je l'ai déjà dit
publiquement être extrêmement favorable
à tous les contrôles et et en nombre
parce que quand je compare la situation
en France des contrôles et de et celle
de nos pays voisins parfois dans
certains pays alentours le contrôle est
plus du strict et plus important et je
pense que c'est normal et je pense que
c'est une des missions des pouvoirs
publics de le faire
alors oui sur j'ai effectivement dit sur
France Info que la Caisse des Dépôts
était la meilleure des solutions que
nous pouvions trouver
mon rôle était de s'assurer qu'il y
avait une solution parce que comme je
l'ai dit dans mon propre introductif
pour les salariés pour les patients et
les résidents d'orpa il fallait trouver
une solution et donc mon rôle comme
directeur général était de m'assurer que
si jamais pour une raison que je ne
comprenais pas mais le plan A qui était
mon plan a d'arrivée de la Caisse des
Dépôts ne fonctionnait pas il me fallait
obligatoirement un plan B parce que je
ne pouvais pas laisser une incertitude
planée qui pouvait venir d'une décision
de la caisse des dépôts un désaccord
avec les créanciers une raison que je ne
maîtrise pas mais j'étais obligé d'avoir
un plan B et ce plan B n'était pas ma
solution privilégiée mais j'étais obligé
d'avoir une autre et voilà pourquoi
peut-être certains au nom déduit que
j'aurais préféré autre chose pas du tout
je suis parfaitement satisfait et au
contraire vous voyez je
pour les patients pour les résidents
pour nos collaborateurs dans dans les
territoires pour nos fournisseurs même
pour nos créanciers il n'y a pas de
meilleure solution pour que que la
Caisse des dépôts est consignations et
MAIF et MACSF pour rassurer tout le
monde et continuer à mettre en place
notre plan de refondation
[Musique]
monsieur le député frappé
je retrouve votre question oui la Caisse
des Dépôts combien de temps elle va elle
va elle va rester je peux pas le dire je
pense que la caisse d'épaule est un
investisseur de long terme ça fait
partie des éléments qui rassurent tout
le monde et évidemment il y a pas
d'engagement il y a pas il y a pas
d'éléments qui qui nous permet de dire
mais dans le système français la Caisse
des dépôts est quand même un
investisseur de très long terme et
accompagne ses participations en général
de façon très longue à très très peu de
sessions donc soyez rassurés je pense
que la caisse des dépôt sera là pour
longtemps s'agissant des visites
inopinées moi je vous invite tous à
passer dans les dans les ehpadorphea
c'est une autorisation personnelle qui
n'engage personne d'autre vous êtes tous
les bienvenus venez
passer du temps avec nos aînés ça leur
fera du bien aussi et je pense que vous
vous apprendrez beaucoup de choses et ce
sera vous pourrez ainsi n'hésitez pas à
me faire remonter les informations que
vous glanez à ces opérations pour que je
puisse moi aussi être parfaitement au
courant venez aussi déjeuner
nos aînés apprécieront énormément que
vous n'ayez déjeuner avec eux
la confiance comment on va et je c’était
votre dernière question monsieur le
député frapper la confiance elle viendra
par les bonnes pratiques elle viendra
des établissements elle viendra de la
qualité de ce qu'on va faire sur le sur
auprès de nos aînés auprès de nos
patients et de nos résidents tous les
jours et donc oui ça sera on mettra du
temps à la retrouver c'est normal la
confiance repère très vite elle met
énormément de temps à se retrouver mais
c'est uniquement par la qualité du
travail sur le terrain tous les jours au
quotidien auprès des nos enecos on
retrouvera la confiance de nos de la
population française et de nos députés
oui monsieur le député Martin j'ai bien
j'ai bien en tête
les sujets et les complexités que posent
enfin c'est pas un sujet complexité
c'est pas acceptable de pas avoir de
directeur de métro et deck dans dans un
établissement
je vais regarder dès en rentrant la
situation de Messi et des terrasses
dessus du Suzon pour être sûr que c'est
bien que c'est bien le cas et que tout a
été corrigé aujourd'hui
je ne peux pas on a une rotation du
personnel qui est extrêmement importante
et sur lequel il faut qu'on travaille ce
que je disais tout à l'heure sur les sur
les rémunérations sur les moyens de
sur les moyens de qu'on met en oeuvre
mais dans ce secteur de façon générale
pas que pas coordé tout le secteur a des
gens qui tournent beaucoup et ça c'est
vraiment un problème parce que après ça
crée des trous dans l'organisation
pendant une semaine deux semaines un
mois deux mois qui sont créateurs de
difficultés et ça c'est un sujet sur
lesquels on travaille je l'ai dit je
me suis engagé à rembourser les sommes à
l'euro l'euro du passé ça a été vrai
pour la CNSA et pour l'intégralité du
montant de la CNSA pour les départements
je crois qu'il faut qu'on ait
département par département une
discussion et que on mettre ça on met ça
en oeuvre dans les dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent
monsieur député Le Gac oui donc comme je
venais de le dire sur la scmsa les 30
millions je pense sur le fond non je
vais le redire je pense que ce montant
de 30 millions nous avions les éléments
pour dire de palomber j'ai décidé de le
rembourser j'ai des plus et de dire oui
on va pas on est en train de refaire une
refondation vous comprenez on a un
travail gigantesque sur les territoires
dans les EHPAD lignes à ligne etc il y a
un moment il faut enlever les cailloux
qu'on a dans le chasse aux chaussures ce
montant était un caillou que j'avais
dans la chaussure j'ai préféré le mettre
derrière moi et courir un peu plus vite
sur les dispositifs qui concernent les
faisant fonction
c'est très clair par ailleurs il y avait
pas assez de formation chez ORPEA avant
et sur les faisans fonctions
on est obligé on est en place un
dispositif de VAE et de proie les deux
dispositifs de façon 3 qui est un
dispositif d'accompagnement également
qui est nouveau qui a été mis en place
par le gouvernement et qui nous permet
également de faire de la qualification
du personnel de façon je trouve aussi
intéressantes en concurrence de la VAE
la VAE il y a du travail de
simplification administrative à faire
parce que c'est un dossier extrêmement
complexe extrêmement lourd je sais que
vous êtes enfier sur le sur le sur le
sujet
avec et on l'attend avec impatience au
travail parce que il sert un vrai sujet
le nombre de de
le nombre de de jury est aussi un sujet
qui faut qu'il faut qu'on règle ensemble
nous avons des
sur le sujet de d'alternance et
d'apprentissage où nous avons pardon
deux
organismes de formation en interne de y
fasse interne qui je dois dire sont en
région parisienne donc ça cause une
difficulté c'est très bien pour la
région parisienne mais pour tous les
territoires
allez déplacer un de nos collègues en
région parisienne avec le logement c'est
une très grande difficulté et donc on
est en train de trouver des accords avec
d'autres instituts de formation pour
pouvoir accélérer nos nos formations et
puis nous allons doubler le nombre
d'alternants
merci monsieur le député
monsieur le député certains je vais
remettre mes lunettes
sur la question des statuts oui j'avais
annoncé déjà au en juillet dernier en
fait quelques semaines après mon arrivée
que je considère que compte tenu de la
nature
de la nature de l'activité qui était
celle d'Orpea passer en entreprise
mission était une chose qui me
paraissait nécessaire donc nous
engageons dans le process d'entreprise
de mission
la seule chose que j'ai dit dans le même
moment c'est que je ne pensais pas je ne
voulais pas faire du un coup de peinture
sur l'entreprise et que donc je ne
voulais pas passer en entreprise
émission immédiatement parce que je
pensais que les fondamentaux étaient à
reconstruire on ne passe pas en
entreprise la mission si on n'a pas les
valeurs on passe pas une entreprise
émission si on n'a pas un projet
d'entreprise collectif et donc il y a un
travail gigantesque à faire et j'allais
dire le noeud sur le travail sera à la
fin sur le cadeau sera de passer en
entreprise émission et ce sera quelque
chose que qu'on fera bien évidemment
et vous avez
dans les dernières secondes posez la
question sur les directions et les
fournisseurs les fournisseurs mon axe
principal de travail c'est toujours le
bien-être de nos patients et nos
résidents il y a des fournisseurs qui
sont des fournisseurs de tout le secteur
et qui sont des fonds d'une clé sur les
protections sur
sur des éléments de soins qui sont
fondamentaux je ne peux pas couper ces
fournisseurs même si leur pratique par
le passé étaient contestables on a
arrêté ces pratiques on a remis les
choses au carré avec des dirigeants de
ces fournisseurs mais je le l'intérêt du
soin l'intérêt de nos patients
commandent et comment nous continuons à
travailler avec eux
et en revanche évidemment toutes les
pratiques du passé ont cessé
et les mêmes fournisseurs que solidaires
les mêmes fournisseurs que ceux avec les
RFA d'hier monsieur le député Guedj
néanmoins les RFA maintenant sont non
pas extérieurs à l'entreprise et
profitant à quelques-uns mais ils sont
intérieurs à l'entreprise et ils sont
quand ils concernent le soin et la
dépendance 100% redonner soit ou à
l'enveloppe soin soit l'enveloppe
dépendance pour s'assurer après
évidemment ça pose un problème éthique
on est d'accord mais quand un
fournisseur a une position extrêmement
forte et extrêmement utile et a la
quarantaine de modèles de la quarantaine
de modèles de protection qui est
nécessaire pour s'assurer que la bonne
protection va sur la bonne personne
c'est notre c'est l'intérêt de du
patient et du résident qui commande
madame la députée panneaux si on pouvait
j'ai bien noté votre votre question sur
sur la marge opérationnelle à 20%.
sachez que le secteur a pris l'habitude
de communiquer sur cette marge mais ce
qu'on paye avec cette marge après c'est
encore tout l'immobilier c'est à dire
que donc quand on dit 20 % on n'a pas
encore payé le loyer et on n'a pas
encore payé les frais centraux
donc et c'est une grande partie le loyer
est une très grande partie plus de la
majorité de ces 20% et après il nous
reste les fraises Santos à payer donc la
marge quand on est à 20% la marge
opérationnelle des activités de soins et
de et de et d'accompagnement et en fait
très faible
Domidom j'ai bien noté votre votre point
je vais on va mettre ça dans le cadre du
dialogue social si vous voulez madame la
députée parce que je pense que ce qui
est très important c'est de passer et de
et que l'entreprise dans l'ensemble de
ses composantes prennent l'habitude de
passer par le dialogue social et par les
instances du dialogue social j'ai bien
noté le poids je vais le faire repasser
à ma directrice de Domidom mais je crois
que c'est un point qui concerne un peu
plus largement que que moi et on va se
on va se pencher sur le sujet sur le
sujet
monsieur le député tâché de la Pagerie
sur le doigt de visite je crois que j'ai
répondu je vous invite à venir dans tous
les dans tous les ehpadorpa et sur la
question de la dignité l'articulation
dignité rentabilité moi je j'ai vraiment
une position ferme sur le sujet je pense
qu'on peut faire
enfin même une condition de gagner sa
vie quand une entreprise c'est de bien
faire son travail
sinon tôt ou tard
on perd de l'argent tôt ou tard on tombe
ton ou tout tard il arrive qu'il arrive
avec ORPEA et donc bien faire son
travail c'est une condition pour être
rentable de façon durable
et la baisse du cours de bourse que qui
est je dirais
incroyable
parce que parce qu'il faut se souvenir
qu'il y a un an et demi le corps de
bourse était à 100 et qu'aujourd'hui on
est plutôt à deux cette baisse du cours
de bourse c'est exactement ça c'est une
entreprise qui ne fait pas bien son
travail qui à un moment le paye et donc
moi je suis totalement convaincu
par mon histoire parce que j'ai fait
dans ma vie en entreprise et au service
de l'État que on peut faire les deux
maintenant la condition sinequanone
c'est de bien faire son travail et c'est
ce à quoi on s'attache tous les jours et
et tous les jours depuis qu'on est
arrivé
madame députée du presirat
combien de contrôle on a eu alors on a
eu
179 contrôles de mémoire je enfin
environ 160 180 contrôle sachant qu'on a
227 établissements en France donc je
pense qu'on a été le groupe le
groupement l'association la plus
contrôlée et c'est normal ça me choque
pas du tout et je l'ai déjà dit mais
revenez quand vous voulez je j'ai une
mon engagement c'est un engagement de
transparence de contrôle c'est normal ça
fait partie de la normalité c'est la
grande majorité de ces contrôles ont été
des contrôles physiques pas uniquement
sur le papier et des contrôles inopinés
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'a pas été prévenus
avant et je trouve ça parfaitement
parfaitement bien sur le ratio minimal
de soignants comme je l'avais indiqué
tout à l'heure je suis extrêmement
favorable je trouve que c'est une une
bonne mesure le nombre de soignant par
comme le l'a dit la défenseur la
défenseur de droit comme vous le dites
régulièrement dans cette assemblée le
nombre de soignants par
résident et est un des critères
fondamentaux de la qualité de ce qu'on
fait et donc j'y suis j'y suis favorable
sur les sujets de Dimitri peut-être
pierre tu veux dire un mot
pardon
oui madame la députée du preschira votre
question précise sur les objectifs
caloriques j'ai envie d'y répondre
d'abord précisément les menus sont
conçus pour atteindre 2200 kcal par jour
ce qui dépasse légèrement les
recommandations de l'ancêtre qui sont de
2000 kg calories par jour et puis en
termes d'apport protéique 85 g de
protéines par jour ce qui dépasse aussi
les recommandations de 70 g par jour
mais au-delà au-delà de ça je voudrais
je voudrais partager avec vous le fait
que il est important de réfléchir
qualitativement à nos repas le repas est
un moment de plaisir en tout cas un
vecteur de plaisir très important pour
pour nos aînés c'est un moment de
convivialité Laurent Guillot l'a dit
c'est un moment où on va apporter des
échanges des échanges sociaux
et donc ce que nous prévoyons ce que
j'aimerais vraiment apporter à la
réflexion de l'entreprise c'est de
réfléchir sur les aspects personnalisés
du repas l'encadrement et puis si vous
voulez d'un point de vue médical
augmenter presque sans limite les
apports caloriques pour tous finalement
à un moment ça ne fait plus sens puisque
certains vont être dépassés par ces
apports en termes de volume en termes
d'envie en termes de demandes et puis
pour d'autres ce sera encore insuffisant
pour des raisons parfois neurologiques
qui qui stimule l'appétit et donc nous
voulons travailler sur les sur la
personnalisation des repas et sur le
plaisir autour du repas ça c'est un
objectif du du projet médico-soignant
qui qui convoque aussi finalement la
réflexion sur tous les plaisirs du
quotidien les petits bonheur monsieur le
député Müller a évoqué le moment de la
toilette c'est un moment extrêmement
important
qui rejoint
l'impératif de formation j'ai envie de
dire formation
et monter en compétences des des
soignants c'est un acte de soins qui va
être disposé à la carte en fonction de
la personne de ses besoins dans son
altération cognitive de son altération
locomotrice et nous devons ajuster les
moyens d'assistance à la toilette de
façon personnalisée voilà ce que je
voulais dire sur sur ces moments qui
rassemble des plaisirs pour nos aînés
je ne sais pas je pense que Madame la
député avait encore vu une question
le jour de l'annonce il y a eu une
augmentation du cours de bourse mais je
crois qu'il faut se situer dans la
longue durée et l'arrivée de la caisse
des consignations on va se traduire par
une dilution massive des actionnaires et
et comme vous le voyez les actionnaires
historiques ont tout perdu
c'est c'est les conséquences de la
mauvaise gestion de l'entreprise et dans
une certaine façon c'est normal
très bien merci Monsieur le Directeur
général nous allons poursuivre avec les
8 autres questions et je passe tout de
suite la parole à Monsieur Arthur
Delaporte
je vous donne le micro
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur je comme ma collègue nous vient
Bouvet le souligner j'ai été aussi très
impliqué dans l'accompagnement donc des
salariés de la filiale dominove donc
notamment de l'agence de Caen qui
s'était engagé dans un conflit social de
45 jours et qui a fini à l'issue de ce
conflit par obtenir une revendication
importante qui était celle de la
revalorisation de l'indemnité
kilométrique à 45 centimes du kilomètre
et qui était déjà une avancée puis des
hausses de salaire aussi importante qui
ont bénéficié et je tiens à le dire à
l'ensemble des salariés du groupe donc
c'est je remercie aussi c'est huit
salariés de cette mobilisé pour cela et
donc je souhaite évidemment et comme
vous l'avez répondu je ne reviendrai pas
dessus que le dialogue social qui a été
engagé des élections professionnelles
qui sont en train d'avoir lieu dans
cette branche qui était auparavant
absolument délaissé et
et puis se tenir et que la négociation
se poursuive donc voilà ça c'est quelque
chose que je salue et donc ça dans le
bon sens maintenant je souhaitais savoir
un petit peu plus d'un point de vue
stratégique comment vous envisagiez
l'avenir de cette filiale puisque il y a
eu dans les échos il y a trois semaines
de cela un article qui disait que le
fond d'investissement KKR serait
intéressé pour reprendre le contrôle de
cette filia de l'aide à domicile qui
représente à peu près 2% donc du chiffre
d'affaires du groupe mais sur lesquels
vous enregistrez des pertes on sait
aujourd'hui que l'avenir notamment de du
vieillissement se situe aussi dans
l'amplification du secteur de l'aide à
domicile donc est-ce que ORPEA entend
lâcher ce sujet ou continuer peut-être à
travers sa filiale de binôme à être un
des acteurs moteur voire exemplaire on
peut le souhaiter sur le sujet et donc
sur la filière de l'aide à domicile
voilà c'était un petit peu le sens de ma
question quel est votre stratégie sur
l'aide à domicile est-ce que c'est en
gros une filiale dont il faut se
débarrasser parce qu'elle est elle
génère des pertes et dans ce cas là si
elle génère des pertes pour ce qui a un
avenir tout simplement pour l'aide à
domicile à ORPEA ou ailleurs
très bien la parole est à Madame Farida
Amrani merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur Guillot au cours du scandale de
maltraitance au sein des établissements
ORPEA nous avions nous apprenions le
rationnement des résidents le
sous-effectif chronique l'insuffisance
du suivi sanitaire le rationnement des
couches mais aussi la répression
syndicale ainsi que les maversations
financières en 2012 la somme versée aux
actionnaires était de 26,5 millions
d'euros puis en 2019 elle le s'élevait à
77,5 millions monsieur Guillot en 7 ans
le groupe ORPEA multiplié par trois la
somme des dividendes versées à ses
actionnaires si la si la mise en place
du rationnement humain systématique est
incontestable tout aussi incontestable
et l'absence de rationnement des profits
réalisés par ce groupe puis plus
récemment afin d'éviter le votre
redressement judiciaire pardon la Caisse
des dépôts à injecté 1,5 milliards
d'euros en faisant elle devient
l'actionnaire principal et majoritaire
du groupe malgré ces révélations qui ont
choqué le pays tout entier
à ce jour aucune remise en cause des
dérives structurelles de l'EHPAD privé
lucratif ni la privatisation du secteur
de la dépendance non eu lieu monsieur
Guillot vous avez récemment déclaré
historiquement hors paient engageait
dégager plutôt des marges autour de 26%
et au premier trimestre au premier
semestre 2022 elles étaient tombées à
17%. nous devons d'abord les redresser
c'est ce que vous avez dit monsieur nous
apprenons qu'en 2022 ORPEA n'a pas versé
de dividendes mais quand sera-t-il dans
les années suivantes surtout quelle
action comptait vous réellement mettre
en œuvre pour empêcher que de tels
humains se produit je sais que vous avez
déjà répondu à cette question là mais
voilà merci merci bien la parole est à
Madame Karen éroti
est devenu le symbole de la maltraitance
de nos personnes âgées le symbole de
l'or gris ignoble expression symbolisant
le profit fait sur le dos et la santé
des résidents en EHPAD depuis
l'apparition des fossoyeurs en janvier
2022 les scandale se sont multipliés en
émus on fait couler beaucoup d'encre
mais si on en croit la défenseuse des
droits rien n'a changé le mois dernier
elle écrivait à ce sujet la réponse est
pouvoir publique n'est pas à la hauteur
de manière polie elle dénonce en réalité
les belles paroles du gouvernement qui
n'ont jamais été suivies des faits
je tiens à souligner la cause première
de tous ces dysfonctionnements
l'insupportable élargissement du marché
au domaine de la au domaine de la santé
et de la dépendance si la nupette était
au pouvoir alors les EHPAD privés
habituent lucratif seraient transformés
en structure associative coopérative ou
publique
en un seul mot sans spéculation et
surtout au service de l'humain d'abord
j'aime bien donc à ma première question
comptez-vous enfin mettre en place la
nécessaire recommandation de la
Défenseur des droits en premier lieu le
respect du ratio du ratio minimum
minimal 8 soignants pour 10 résidents
dans les EHPAD ensuite je viens à
l'entrée de la Caisse des dépôts au
capital horpa la presse nous a informé
des dimensions des dissensions pardon
entre vous monsieur Guillot et Guillaume
Pepy président d'Orpea on apprend que
vous avez essayé par l'intermédiaire de
Rothschild de faire entrer des fonds
étrangers au capital à la place de la
Caisse des Dépôts monsieur Guillot je
vous demande donc craignez-vous
craignez-vous à ce point la diminution
des dividendes liées à l'entrée de la
Caisse des Dépôts si c'est le cas vous
êtes autant si c'est le cas si vous êtes
autant obsédé par la rentabilité alors
je crains que ma réponse à ma je crains
la réponse pardon à ma première question
je vous en remercie
très bien la parole est à Madame Rachel
kéké
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur général comme tout le monde le
sait la sortie du livre les fossoyeurs
du journaliste Vincent Castanet a permis
de mettre la lumière sur la maltraitance
de beaucoup de nos aînés dans vos
différents établissements en mai 2021 la
défense des droits vous a fait 64
recommandations concernant OPA le 16
janvier dernier un nouveau rapport sur
le suivi des recommandations et je
trouve assez sévère vous concernant on
lit dans ce nouveau rapport que depuis
mai 2021 la Défenseur des droits a été
saisi par 291 nouvelle réclamations de
nos sons des atteintes au droit de
nombreuses directives n'ont pas été
mises en place comme par exemple
l'urgence d'un ratio minimal
d'encadrement avec notamment l'objectif
de huit équivalents temps plein pour 10
résidents des professionnels déclarants
préférés quitter leur poste plutôt que
continuer à travailler dans des
conditions qui les rendent eux-mêmes
complices de la maltraitance je suis
convaincu que de bonnes conditions de
travail amène de bonnes conditions de
prise en charge de nos seniors aussi je
me demande quand en est-il des questions
de sous-traitance quel secteurs sont
impactés par cela actuellement la
restauration l'entretien quand avez-vous
mis en place pour vous rassurer que pour
vous rassurer que pardon les conditions
de travail sont respectées serez-vous
prêt à nous communiquer les noms des
boîtes de sous-traitance pour mieux
comprendre les conditions de travail
merci
très bien la parole est à Madame Fanta
Beretti merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Professeur merci pour vos présentations
j'étais en ami cycle au démarrage
j'espère ne pas être redondante avec un
de vos propos parmi les quatre axes de
travail que vous proposez il y a celui
de l'enrichissement de l'impact
économique et social des entreprises du
groupe étant membre du groupe d'études
sur le SS à l'Assemblée cet axe
m'intéresse naturellement dans un
rapport publié en 2022 de l'université
Gustave Eiffel et de la chaîne
d'économie sociale et solidaire
intitulée le SS dans la petite enfance
et le grand âge à leur néolibérale il
est noté que les EHPAD privé lucratifs
subissent une gestion marquée par une
pression financière caractérisée par une
hiérarchisation des indicateurs de
qualité avec un indicateur prégnant qui
est le taux d'occupation pour rompre
avec la pression financière sur les
EHPAD le rapport suggère notamment
d'inscrire ces établissements à partir
de leur territoire et ce sur un modèle
de société Coopérative d'Intérêt
collectifs
c'est ici la SCI c est une structure
juridique qui associe donc les
entreprises classiques des collectivités
territoriales des instituts de recherche
et aussi des personnes physiques
notamment des citoyens et des bénévoles
au regard de vos objectifs et des
atteintes de des attentes pardon de la
population il est certainement
nécessaire de vous réinterroger afin que
les acteurs du grand âge lesquels vous
faites partie puisse avoir un impact de
social positif dans la société ma
question est donc la suivante quelles
sont vos pistes de travail au regard de
ce type de modèle j'ai bien entendu
votre réponse concernant les entreprises
à mission par ailleurs tout à l'heure
très bien Madame Caroline janvier
merci madame la Présidente alors moi je
voudrais vous interroger sur le modèle
économique de de l'EHPAD commercial
voyez-vous ici au sein de cette
commission nous avons eu beaucoup de
débats au moment de la publication du
livre de Monsieur Castanet et certains
allant même et je pense notamment aux
précédents présidents de l'Assemblée
nationale Richard Ferrand et bien a
évoqué l'hypothèse de d'un modèle
d'accompagnement de nos aînés sans EHPAD
privé lucratif sans structure
commerciale donc qui reposerait
uniquement sur des EHPAD public ou des
privés associatifs privés non lucratifs
je pose cette question là puisque si
nous avons finalement préféré renforcer
les les processus de contrôle et donc
quelque part diminuer les marges
d'autonomie du secteur public du secteur
privé associatif nous nous posons
maintenant la question quand nous voyons
effectivement la feuille de route de la
CDC qui dit que les actionnaires devront
s'habituer à des rémunérations plus
faibles la session d'un stade des
actions du fond de pension canadien qui
a perdu beaucoup d'argent dans cette
histoire et donc c'est vrai que
j'aimerais moi être éclairé sur la façon
dont vous pensez que cela est réellement
possible de combiner le respect d'un
certain nombre d'exigences éthiques d'un
certain nombre de principes de bien
traitance et de qualité d'accompagnement
avec et bien un modèle lucratif et ce
n'est pas un gros mot mais mais mais
mais voilà c'est une question importante
je vous remercie
merci bien la parole est à Madame
Laurence Cristol
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur le
Professeur ma question rejoint en fait
les dernières échanges avec mes
collègues bien entendu sur le plan du
personnel des EHPAD on sait bien qu'un
personnel bien traité est un personnel
bien traitant et que pour l'espérer on
doit insister donc sur sur la formation
l'accompagnement et je sais qu'en propos
liminaire vous avez parlé du dialogue
social et également des mesures que vous
avez mis en place en terme de
recrutement et de formation ces points
là me semblent important mais ma
question est plus plus globale si vous
le permettez aujourd'hui avec l'avancée
en âge et le vieillissement de la
population et de la perte d'autonomie on
se rend compte que le modèle des EHPAD
est peut-être aujourd'hui en train de
changer
j'ai connu les EHPAD à un moment où
c'était
plus des lieux de vie qu'aujourd'hui
avec des patients enfin des patients
excusez-moi des résidents qui étaient
admis justement à un âge où il pouvait
se permettre de pouvoir bénéficier d'un
plan de réhab d'adaptation de soutien
d'accompagnement pendant plusieurs
années aujourd'hui la situation a
énormément évolué en espace de quelques
années et on se retrouve plus avec des
patients que des résidents donc ma
question est avez-vous
des pistes des réflexions sur la façon
dont on doit pouvoir imaginer le devenir
la vie de ces personnes plus
âgées plus en perte d'autonomie au sein
de ce modèle des pattes que nous
connaissons à ce jour et qui n'est
absolument pas le modèle des services de
long séjour que nous connaissions il y a
une vingtaine d'années et je vous
remercie merci bien et nous en arrivons
à la dernière question de madame la
députée Katiana Levavasseur à qui je
passe la parole
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Directeur Monsieur le directeur médical
nous aimerions vous faire confiance sur
les réponses que vous vous apportez car
vous êtes dans la lumière et vous devez
être irréprochable
nous voulons savoir qui participe au
conseil de la vie sociale et en ce qui
concerne les arrêts maladie nous avons
constaté qu'il se produisent le matin à
froid ne pensez-vous pas qu'il serait
nécessaire de changer les rythmes de
travail des soignants c'est à dire les
échéanciers sur la journée pour
prodiguer les soins merci
merci bien et bien voilà Monsieur le
Directeur Général la troisième salle de
question et je vous laisse la parole
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
j'ai bien noté la question du député de
la porte et la question des indemnités
kilométriques qui revient et donc je
ferai la même réponse qu'à madame la
députée
qu'on allait regarder le sujet
sur l'avenir de l'activité du domicile
dans le groupe ORPEA la rumeur selon
laquelle KKR est intéressé et serait en
train d'acheter de medum et complètement
infondé il n'y a pas il n'y a pas il n'y
a pas du tout de de
discussion et je ne souhaite pas en
avoir après il y a une vraie question de
fond qui est de bien trouver l'équilibre
et le modèle économique du domicile avec
des contraintes qui sont
extrêmement fortes mais aussi et c'est
important des
sujet de protection de nos patients et
de nos résidents de suivi de la qualité
des soins à domicile qui est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué j'allais dire plus
compliqué encore que dans les EHPAD ou
il y a un collectif il y a un directeur
d'établissement qui est là en permanence
il y a
l'équipe soignante qui est proche et qui
dès qu'il y a une
un comportement qui n'est pas adéquat
peut immédiatement agir dans le domicile
c'est plus compliqué et donc c'est une
sujet c'est un sujet sur lesquels on
réfléchit beaucoup pour trouver à la
fois le modèle de bien traitance le plus
adapté et le modèle économique qui fait
que cette activité est intéressante et
par ailleurs s'il y avait intéressante
pour nous et ça veut dire aussi qu'elle
est intéressant pour pour tous les
autres intervenants du secteur donc
c'est c'est un vrai c'est un vrai sujet
madame
c'est parti madame madame la députée
l'augmentation des dividendes par 3 je
suis arrivé en je suis arrivé en juillet
dernier donc tout ce qui concerne avant
juillet dernier
je dois dire je n'en prends pas beaucoup
de responsabilités j'en prends j'en
prends la responsabilité des
conséquences et ça c'est très important
et parce que il y a une dette d'orpa
vis-à-vis de ces personnels vis-à-vis de
ses patients et de ses résidents qui
font aussi qu'il faut aussi traiter
d'une certaine de certains points de vue
oui j'ai dit que les marches il fallait
les redresser parce que dans les 17%
comme je l'ai dit à Madame A député pas
de notion ou V dans cette marge de 17%
je dois payer encore les loyers je dois
payer les équipes au siège qui
travaillent et que 17% c'est insuffisant
mais ça veut pas dire ça veut pas dire
que
au coeur de mon projet au cœur du projet
comporte avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe parce que c'est
pas moi un homme tout seul qui peut
redresser cette entreprise il y a aussi
et il y a surtout il y a principalement
le soin et l'accompagnement on payera
pas de dividendes en effet en 2022 et
compte tenu de la situation de
l'entreprise on en payera pas non plus
dans les dans les années qui viennent je
crois que le principal projet pour
l'instant c'est vraiment de remettre
l'entreprise au carré remonte
l'entreprise sur les rails
vous avez madame la députée roadie vous
m'avez posé deux questions une sur la
Défenseur des droits et sur le taux
d'encadrement
entre des soignants et les résidents
comme je disais tout à l'heure dans mon
propre éliminaire je suis moi
extrêmement favorable à ce qu'on met
on définisse des critères d'encadrement
et mais j'allais dire avec un durée
d'adaptation parce que le vrai sujet
c'est si on dit aujourd'hui voilà quel
est le taux on a un sujet de recrutement
on a un sujet de formation on a un sujet
d'avoir réellement ces personnes sur le
sur le parce qu'on peut virer on peut
dire sur le papier
que
qu'on met ce critère mais si on n'est
pas capable de le faire réellement donc
moi j'y suis favorable mais mais disons
avec le temps pour former les équipes
pour pouvoir avoir le monde réellement
sur le terrain c'est ça qui m'importe
vous avez fait vous avez fait tas de ma
supposée préférence pour des fonds
d'investissement plutôt que la caisse
des dépôt est consignations j'ai déjà
répondu à cette question mais je vais
vous le redire puisque je crois que
c'est important non ma situation
privilégiée était celle de l'arrivée de
la Caisse des Dépôts et Consignation
mais je devais je me devais en
responsabilité comme chef d'entreprise
prévoir tous les cas et toutes les
solutions y compris celles ou la caisse
des bruits de consignation ne souhaitait
pas venir ou pour une contrainte
quelconque ne pouvait pas venir et avoir
donc un plan B je vais dire heureusement
et après de longues discussions
nocturnes et avec la Caisse des pots et
consignations et avec les nous avons
fait aboutir le plan et je m'en réjouis
tous les jours
madame la députée kéké vous avez revenu
très longuement sur le rapport de la
Défenseur des droits et vous avez raison
ce rapport est très important très
intéressant il ne concerne pas hors pa
en tant que tel il concerne tout le
secteur
et et porte des recommandations qui me
semble être très importante elle me
semble tellement importante que nous
avons décidé de façon interne d'en faire
un suivi ligne à ligne de ces 64
recommandations avec le professeur
Pierre crolaxalmont pour voir comment
nous progressions et avoir des
indicateurs de progression sur sur ce
rapport et donc je vous le confirme
que nous sommes et nous allons rester
une entreprise à but lucratif mais une
entreprise à but lucratif qui fait son
travail qui prend soin de ses patients
de ses résidents et qui prend soin de
ses collaborateurs parce que sans
prendre soin des collaborateur il n'y a
pas de soin des des résidents et des
patients
madame la députée béreté m'a posé la
question
[Musique]
ah oui sur la rivièreisation la
hiérarchisation des critères ça c'est
une excellente question là
hiérarchisation des critères
vous voyez les critères qui étaient dans
les dans les
bonus et dans les critères de
rémunération de mon prêt de mes
prédécesseurs étaient principalement axé
sur les indicateurs financiers et de
développement quand à mon arrivée j'y ai
spécifiquement demandé ça faisait partie
de mes conditions pour arriver que le
premier critère qui était le mien dans
ma rémunération soit le critère qui
porte sur la bien traitance et
l'accompagnement des personnes que nous
avions dans nos établissements que ce
soit des résidents ou des patients et ça
représente 40% de Arménie ma
rémunération variable 30% étant sur des
critères financiers et 30% sur des
critères j'allais dire généraux de de
performance décidée par le conseil
d'administration donc vous voyez et je
pense que c'est un élément extrêmement
important c'est la même chose dans les
établissements c'est à dire que les
directeurs d'établissements qui
historique était avait un bonus sur des
critères financiers aujourd'hui
80% de leur rémunération variable sont
sur des critères qui ont trait aux soins
à l'accompagnement à la sécurité dans
les dans leurs établissements et ça
c'est un changement fondamental dans le
dans la façon même d'apporter les
budgets
on a des on a des indicateurs de de
satisfaction on a des indicateurs de ei
de IG donc de d'événements indésirables
graves premier pardon je vais revenir
sur des points techniques mais le
premier chose que j'ai faite en arrivant
c'est de demander que me soit reporté
toutes les semaines
chacun individuellement chacun des
événements indésirables graves et que
c'est ces événements qui étaient
historiquement envoyés aux ARS avec dans
un délai moyen de 15 jours sont
maintenant envoyés dans un délai
inférieur à 2 jours qui me soit remonté
et qu'on les regarde donc dans un
premier temps ça va se traduire par une
augmentation des EIG pourquoi non pas
parce qu'il y en a plus mais juste parce
que on les déclare et donc ça c'est
fondamental donc moi je suis satisfait
entre guillemets ainsi on peut se parler
franchement je suis satisfait de cette
augmentation parce que maintenant je
sais ce qui se passe un peu plus
beaucoup mieux et ça veut dire que après
chaque événement il y a un pro un plan
d'action il y a un programme d'action et
qu'on vérifie que ce programme nation
est mis en place et est mis en oeuvre
c'est vraiment fondamental pierre tu
veux peut-être commenter ou non
oui bien sûr
prenez le micro
je vous le donne
prenez le micro pardon j'ai appuyé donc
j'étais vraiment sur le modèle de
structure juridique parce que ce qui me
paraît c'est intéressant si je recoupe
la question de la députée cristal par
exemple qui dit que
ces gens-là deviennent des patients le
fait de pouvoir faire rentrer aussi
beaucoup plus de bénévoles de la société
civile etc c'est également pour moi un
moyen en fait de maintenir aussi
ces personnes là avant qu'elle devienne
vraiment patient patients etc donc la
structure on a parlé d'entreprises à
mission mais est-ce que c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait vous intéresser ou
vers lequel vous pourriez aller en
montrant l'exemple
oui on n'a pas prévu de de bouger sur ce
enfin d'aller vers ce modèle on a prévu
d'aller vers une une entreprise émission
et pour aller dans votre sens de
renforcer les conseils de la vie sociale
dans les établissements en incluant
beaucoup plus de personnes beaucoup plus
de monde et de créer un niveau de
conseil de la vie sociale qui soit pas
uniquement au niveau de l'établissement
mais qui soit aussi au niveau régional
pour pouvoir je dirais donner un peu de
conseils et de soutien aux familles qui
dans un con dans un conseil de la vie
sociale se trouve parfois un tout petit
peu seul d'abord parce que elles sont
pas toutes ne s'engage pas dans le CVS
mais aussi toute n'ont pas l'habitude et
gérer la
le talent ou le temps pour s'engager
autant qu'on devrait et donc avoir un
comité de la vie sociale régional qui
pourrait leur apporter des conseils leur
dire ce qui se passe dans cet autre
conseil et avoir des échanges nous
semblait être un moyen
de répondre à cette nécessité qui est
qui est en effet très importante de
mieux centrer sur le territoire et de
faire venir de façon plus ouverte les
gens dans nos établissements les
établissements sont d'orpa ont une
tradition d'être plutôt j'allais des
établissements qui sont fermés et ce que
on veut faire et le changement convaincu
c'est vraiment de l'ouvrir et de
l'ouvrir à tout le monde parce que c'est
une nécessité aussi pour nos pour nos
résidents
madame la députée janvier sur le modèle
économique je pense avoir répondu déjà
moi je considère qu'on a
qu'on a besoin d'une certaine
diversité dans les modèles et pour
essayer de voir lequel est le meilleur
ou qu'est-ce qui peut apporter quoi dans
le temps les voyez les EHPAD privés si
je remontre aux années 80-90 elles ont
apporté
des EHPAD privés à ce moment-là une
amélioration très sensible sur la
qualité de l'hébergement dans dans
cette époque et moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui enfin en tout cas ce que
je souhaite faire
d'orpa c'est un modèle sur la qualité
qui peut servir de modèle à l'ensemble
de de des entreprises par de loin on a
un travail gigantesque à faire et mais
j'ai du temps et l'arrivée de la caisse
des dépôt est consignation de ce point
de vue là est aussi un gage du temps
long et de permettre de progresser de
façon
importante et l'autre l'autre sujet en
termes de qui va avec cette sujet de
diversité
des modèles entre publics privés
lucratif et puis privé associatif c'est
qu'il y a un besoin très très
fondamental de maillage du territoire ce
qui signifie des investissements
dans pour être sûr qu'on a un maillage
complet parce que les personnes qui
viennent dans nos établissements veulent
être près de leur famille veulent être
prêts de ou de là où elles ont vécu et
il faut qu'il y ait suffisamment
d'investissement et ça je pense que le
privé de est de nature et à la capacité
de le faire
madame Christol madame la député Cristol
sur la perte d'autonomie je vais je vais
peut-être parce que c'est une très très
bonne question je vais la passer à
Pierre non pas que j'ai pas des éléments
de réponse mais avec son expérience de
médecin il a plus de réponses que moi
le mode
merci Madame pour ces pour cette
question qui qui souligne une évolution
sociétale
incontestable et ça a été très bien
rapporté par mes collègues Olivier
Guérin et Claude Jeandel dans leur
rapport qui montent la nécessité de
médicalisation plus forte des maisons de
retraite alors que les unités de soins
de longue durée pour être dédiées à des
à des soins plus pointus plus
spécialisés et donc vous faites
référence à la continuité de d'aide et
de soins qu'on peut apporter à nos aînés
à partir du domicile jusqu'à des
établissements de plus en plus
médicalisés
vous savez peut-être que
la moyenne d'âge augmente dans ces
établissements au sein de ORPEA la
moyenne d'âge est à 88,9 ans presque 89
ans
et la durée de séjour dans les
établissements et de deux ans et demi
donc on la population concernée est en
grande majorité très très dépendantes et
présente des polypathologies des des
maladies
qui se combinent et qui combine leur
impact de sévérité je voudrais qu'on
réfléchisse vraiment intensément dans le
groupe sur la continuité d'aide qu'on
peut apporter depuis le domicile jusqu'à
des structures ambulatoires jusqu'à
l'hébergement que ce ne soit pas un jour
je suis à domicile le lendemain je suis
en EHPAD qui est peut-être des une
approche beaucoup plus progressive les
hébergements temporaires à l'étranger
que que je visite actuellement il y a
des hébergements qui sont proposés de
durée très très courte et qui permettent
au seniors de d'échanger de rencontrer
d'autres personnes de bénéficier
d'assistance de courte durée et de se
familiariser à la communauté je pense
qu'on peut aussi inventer des nouveaux
supports à domicile des nouveaux
supports ambulatoire
qui vont adoucir cette transition et
vraiment personnaliser l'aide qu'on peut
qu'on peut apporter c'est un vaste
chantier extrêmement pertinent pour
qu'on propose des soins et une aide à la
carte qui soit beaucoup plus continues
et 12 pour nous pour nous aider
et Madame Levavasseur la députée
vous aviez deux questions l'un sur la
participation au CVS elle est elle est
j'allais dire trop faible
malheureusement donc il faut qu'on il
faut qu'on travaille beaucoup plus sur
sur comment attirer et notamment des
gens qui sont en dehors de la proximité
immédiate de nos établissements pour les
faire vivre et les faire vivre de façon
plus plus intense qu'aujourd'hui et sur
la question des arrêts maladie à froid
ça c'est un point auquel j'ai été tout
toujours sensible vous savez dans
beaucoup de Néo usines notamment en Asie
de chez Saint-Gobain nous faisions avant
d'arriver des exactement du stretching
de des exercices pour
s'échauffer et ne pas ne pas avoir les
accidents qui sont les accidents du
début de Tour d'usine parce que c'est
effectivement un moment où on est à
froid et si comme quand on fait du sport
si on s'échauffe pas avant on risque des
des points et donc ça c'est des sujets
sur lesquels il va falloir qu'on
travaille prendre les 5 minutes des
chauffants le matin c'est c'est une
bonne idée après il faut faire attention
on peut pas toujours décaler certaines
missions dans le temps parce qu'il faut
s'adapter à la vie de nos patients et de
nos résidents et le point fondamental
c'est vraiment que nos soignants nos
auxiliaires de vie soient là au moment
où il y en a besoin et pas que
l'organisation de travail dicte la vie
de nos patients et nos résidents c'est
vraiment dans l'autre sens qu'il faut
concevoir les choses c'est à dire avoir
une organisation du travail qui s'adapte
à la vie réelle et aux besoins réels de
nos patients et nos résidents par
exemple certains veulent se lever à 8
heures le matin d'autres veulent se
lever à 10h il faut que notre
organisation du travail s'adapte à ces
conditions c'est pareil pour le déjeuner
et pour et pour et pour le coucher ça
c'est un gros gros et qu'on a à faire
parce que la discussion dans un
établissement autour du planning parce
que ça touche aussi la vie personnelle
et est une discussion qui est toujours
un peu difficile et pareil le moins on a
de monde le plus c'est difficile
merci Monsieur monsieur directeur
général ne partez pas tout de suite je
crois ah il y a un vote
bon alors monsieur le directeur avait
une petite conclusion mais si vous êtes
pressé voilà je voulais juste vous
remercier vraiment vous remercier
chaleureusement pour votre accueil et
pour la qualité de vos questions et je
voulais surtout vous dire que je reste à
votre disposition si vous voulez
continuer les échanges sur ce thème ou
sur d'autres je suis toujours à votre
disposition pour
dit merci bien Monsieur le Directeur je
me permets effectivement le député à
l'oser l'a dit nous avons envie de vous
faire confiance en tous les cas ce que
sachez que nous souhaitons votre
réussite parce que nous souhaitons le
bien-être de nos aînés donc voilà et
bien sûr et des bonnes conditions bonne
condition de travail également de nos
professionnels de santé donc voilà nous
prêtons donc une attention toute
particulière bien sûr à l'évolution donc
du groupe ORPEA et bien mes chers
collègues on se retrouve nous demain à
8h45
en application effectivement donc de
l'article 91 pour poursuivre pour
examiner à la fois les amendements et
poursuivre l'examen du texte dans le
cadre de la réforme sur les retraites
voilà bon appétit et encore une fois
merci Monsieur le Directeur Général
également pour la qualité de vos
réponses merci